here we go ladies and gentlemen like i
said we don't have an opening for the
sidetrack show no
[ __ ] [ __ ] i don't know oh you know
what it was because i nearly [ __ ]
spilled that drink so this is all in a
different spot tom is just like a
walking disaster like it's it's always
like two minutes before the show's gonna
start and he comes in and he's like
knocking the table over his drink goes
flying he did catch it though i caught
that drink in mid-air
he was like and only phil spilled a few
ice cubes
he was on top this thing started tilting
him and i didn't even think about it
it just happened it's so [ __ ] fast
it's lightning replay whatever
it's it's the unconscious that does
whatever does poltergeist
does that you should try and like catch
some flies with chopsticks
no you can't try it it just has to
happen
well i'm not saying that you have to
like try it you could just you could
have some chopsticks around
yeah and then if it so happened that
housefly kind of came on the scene
and [ __ ] look man if you just saw that
[ __ ] he was
sandra she's making up new names every
day she's
it's a sexy little skinny [ __ ] german
girl
runs around i need a tube top
eating peanut butter i told her about
peanut butter so now she's like the
peanut butter ambassador to germany
and now she calls herself what's it
sonic not just an empty boot
not just the empty boob this last time i
got last time i got loaded and
started talking about booze she loves
that [ __ ]
and then i i was talking talking about
that one
um british actress who was david bowie's
ex-girlfriend she was
also like a singer and a dancer and a
recording artist and she worked at a
studio recording studio
and i said see she and she had a [ __ ]
awesome set of [ __ ] she had an
awesome rack
she was in that movie but the people
that time forgot
and uh i said she had a [ __ ] great
rag man [ __ ] nice boobs and she
wasn't she could do all this [ __ ] she
wasn't just an empty boob
and jenny laughed when i said that
evidently sander liked that [ __ ] too
that was pretty funny i thought you were
talking about me though
yeah yeah i guess i'll talk about you
but i said it about her first
yeah i guess you just didn't notice so
she wasn't just some empty boobs
and then and then later on in the show i
noticed i said see she's not just an
empty boob because you can do all those
writing books and stuff
all that writing books and stuff like i
do making stuff well we were talking
about your game
that's right yeah i'm still working on
that i don't think that was the same
episode
well i don't know it was it's hard to
tell because all of our episodes uh
really go either boob-centric or
food-centric you know or both
she's blaming it on me i didn't i didn't
say anything about that
i didn't say who was i didn't say whose
intention it was
i just said they they go like that you
know what i'm saying sometimes
um most of the time it depends on how
close the show is to those injections
when was the last time you had one this
morning oh okay
yeah see i don't know anymore because
you fit you did them you can do them on
your own now yeah
so i don't have to do them so it's like
you you can do them
he's going to be all oily over there
yeah like little stink lines will start
coming off him
yeah she starts smelling like a
teenager's dirty sock
i know right i'm gonna have to like i
got febreze down there i'll spray you
with febreze and it'll all be like
yeah guys said i got a cool
man toy a co2 cartridge fire bb gun
crossman brand
i was i was you know it was one of the
things i wanted to say it was
for some reason i was thinking about
that today
just watching these guys talking about
using 22 caliber pistols that's like
survival tools you know to hunt
squirrels and birds in case
you know [ __ ] the zombie apocalypse
comes and you have to live off the land
and they're showing these they're you
know they're probably representing
companies that are trying to sell these
pistols you know
because i've been thinking so now that
that's not what you want because
22 blows right through [ __ ] squirrels
makes a lot of noise and they're not
very effective you gotta shoot them two
or three times
they're [ __ ] hanging by the tree lips
though oh no don't shoot me again
doesn't she be here
[Music]
squirrels don't apply any resistance to
a
even even the smallest bullet like a 22
long rifle
it just zings through them almost kind
of surgically
it's like stabbing it with an ice pick
it doesn't do much trauma to it other
than just
torture the goddamn thing you just gotta
fill it full of holes if it's not a head
shot they just run off with a hole in
them
it does kill them but man it's it's not
very efficient
and you're just shooting up a lot of
expensive 20 the best thing for survival
is a [ __ ] pump or you could use co2
a pump air rifle that can fire pellets
and if you have the pellet mold the 17
caliber pellet mold
you can keep yourself in pellets for for
your whole life
and they're like well where are you
going to get that lead you steal the
lead
off the car wheels the wheel weights you
see it we
see a car wait [ __ ] just take that
[ __ ] back to the campfire melt it in
there and
drop it down into the bullet mold and
you sit there and make
17 caliber pellets all day long
sure you did yeah and that does it's a
lot more effective on a on little things
like birds and
and uh squirrels it's not moving that
fast
and um they tend to be pretty accurate
and they're totally silent
so you're not giving away your position
silent but deadly
yeah and you don't have to yeah you
don't have to
give very many pumps to it the weaker it
is the more effective it is on those
squirrels it's like throw a rock on them
it'll hit them and they oh and they they
had a
they had a term i don't know if it ever
turned out to be scientifically true it
was called bullet time it was for how
long a bullet was actually
in the body of the target working the
slower it is the longer it was in there
and that i think with real small game
that might matter
not with bigger stuff but with smaller
stuff it might matter
based on what i've seen but you have to
see slow motion shots of how
going through there you know and a gel
test doesn't matter
people put too much weight in jail and
jail testing [ __ ]
thank you mr roboto what do you think or
i should have said domo arigato yeah mr
roboto
what do you say it says so squirrel talk
interesting
yeah is it i don't know that's up to you
to decide
tammy says if anybody's missing their
wheel weights ask tom yeah right
yeah molded them [ __ ] they've molded
that [ __ ] into bullets [ __ ] man
yeah yeah okay oh i thought you were
gonna like keep talking no
all right so back in the 1800s those
cowboys molded their own bullets
yeah yeah i knew that was they did they
molded their own bullets and all over
the campfire okay neglect
no i was saying camp guys said we had a
child killed by a 177
about five to ten years ago hit him
right in the heart you have to have him
yeah that's a little kid yeah 17 caliber
pellet yeah
if you put enough power behind it it can
do something similar to a 22.
that's why i like the pump pump uh air
guns
so you can vary the power you can get a
weak shot
on something real small or pumping up
something a little more powerful you
know
for like a rabbit you know but for a
real small game man
firearms now air gun air guns a lot more
efficient and it's quiet
you know why are you calling attention
to yourself hold all that [ __ ] noise
down
tom yeah
he's telling other people to be quiet
yeah yeah that's like that's really yeah
i know so yeah so uh we got a big box
from dj maniac yesterday yes
yes we did and it had all those
magazines in it like he said it was
gonna send
and also this other cool [ __ ] here look
at well okay so first there was all this
code there was all this cool [ __ ]
there was this uh this postcard here
right
the house of mysterious secrets which is
super cool
trying not to like [ __ ] [ __ ] up the
stream
there you go there's that and then
there's all
you know for those of you who are
tripping right now oh
you didn't get okay and then look
garbage pail kids
i have a couple of these too although i
do not have this one this is what is it
what are they called
tact trent presumably not trent reznor
although it might be
um that looks like something he'd be
into and uh also again
for those who are tripping there you go
and then look at this cool [ __ ] here
so first we have
this little fella who i kind of he looks
like the invisible mate dude he's all
clear and stuff
he has this little he has this little
thing and you can also
wait hold on you can also take that off
and then put on this little baghead
thing
like that see
yeah now dj maniac made all these i
think he made these
i think and then okay these are super
cool
yeah look at this look at this yeah
look at it it's alex from a clockwork
orange
look how cute that is oh my god i love
it he's got an old stick and everything
and then this is tom's favorite right
here
look it's little bitty it's a crust
it's a little snake it's a little tiny
snake pluskin
yeah let me see i call him lil crustle
yeah it looks craft built
these little crusts but real well made
that's so awesome yeah maybe hand
painted
i think so dj says uh i didn't make
these but i know you're tasting movies
and voices
i've never seen this snake blitzkin i
don't know what series that came from
they're cool though yeah he's so cute
and he's so good i think maybe i did
though i think that i think you could
buy that in a
in a uh a thing like a star wars action
figure i think it came with a gun
garden snake garden snake blitzkit
that's awesome so they're like they're
going to hang out over here together
right now i think i showed my mothman
didn't i
my [ __ ] yeah i'm pretty sure
now where's
i just bought that okay and then there
was this
what i was telling you guys about
earlier
i said a whole bunch heavy metal
magazines
yeah yeah they're a lot of them look
like they're from 2012
around that time period but i was
looking inside
i haven't had a chance to read any of
them but looking inside
some of these stories actually look like
some of the stories from the 70s
but some of it looks new and some of it
looks classic
well so maybe some of them are reprints
or they or they had somebody like redo
them
i think i think they were going through
there and maybe um showing some of the
older
classic stuff too
yeah that would be that would be the
thing yeah because then people that were
younger and they were buying them like
nowadays yeah or whenever they came out
would be like oh look at the old [ __ ]
yeah but these things these were great
they all kind of had that kind of a
frank rosetta vibe to them
and um they were all kind of
they had some weird city [ __ ] right
there yeah they were and they were they
were kind of sexy
yeah actually there was one in here that
had like a fetish theme going on
now there some of them are in kind of
rough condition but i could probably
finish it or uh it's not finished it'll
be called uh restore it
yeah well there you go boobs
they had one where a fetish girl came
out of the mouth of another fetish girl
like she turned herself inside out i'm
gonna go back and look at that man i
hate when that happens yeah you never
know when that might happen yeah
i've had that happen so many years i
can't even count
[ __ ] man i turned myself inside out
again
yeah i don't know if they're still
making this kind of stuff anymore this
is what i grew up with though
they had this all the way back in the
late 70s midsection yeah he said they're
all modern but
they're all modern that pokey comes in
and starts looking oh
no she's gonna like you know how she's
looking look at look at she's like oh i
can tear this up
yay yeah don't let her don't let her
don't let her can't turn that out i know
what she's thinking
oh she looked she tried to catch it okay
she's like no don't take it don't take
it yeah
yeah she came up on my uh on my desk
earlier
i don't know why because i got that i
got that um
that grooming glove you know well
actually i got two of them i got one for
her and i got one for
uh mr mcguire because beijing already
has one and uh
so i i was petting her other day with
that and she was really into it
so i think she jumped up on the desk
thinking that i was gonna but i was
trying to eat tacos at the time so she's
like running all over my desk all over
my computers
and getting hair all over everything and
i'm like god damn it i
could eat tacos with like pookie's hair
in there
but you know whatever she has hair
everywhere i'm sure i've probably eaten
a lot of her hair at this
stage also uh wanted to give a shout out
to
louie we just got this probably like an
hour ago
and he sent us the blu-ray
of collateral with tom cruise
and jamie foxx there we go yeah that's
the second one of those we had actually
though
the first one was a dvd yeah we had a
dvd we got a dvd we haven't gotten
around to watching it yeah we haven't
watched it yet though
and uh also here is look at this this is
the steelbook edition
what is that of top gun oh okay yeah
that's me cool yeah
that that was the first [ __ ] gay air
force movie
uh that we know of the first game
it's a homo erotic movie it is there was
a lot of that going on in the 80s yeah
it's a good movie
it's a good movie though that was a lot
of fun well we we would
kind of laugh at it saying it was homo
erotic it wasn't blatant but there was
an undertone
i don't know i think it was pretty
bleeding not as not a girl
not as blatant than mine going through
it as um what's that other one
[ __ ] man you know what i'm talking about
no the one with arnold schwarzenegger in
it
uh well he was in a lot of movies i know
that
you know which one i'm talking about the
one was [ __ ] the dude with the
fishnet shirt
that was supposed to be like what the
[ __ ] amanda yeah there you go commando
yeah i couldn't remember the name of it
whatever reason i'm having commander was
kind of like a
like a video game and a music video all
put together what's up poop
i was talking about i was talking about
uh pookie's hair getting in
my lunch and mr obata says hairy taco
now trending
esther said did you get your package
daddy not uh no not yet
not today but uh i got one from louie
today but that was it
the dude with the arms and the hair so
yeah thank you yeah thank you
thanks thanks for uh thank you for dj
maniac you guys are
awesome yeah you guys are awesome what
else was i going to say oh
i was saying something about uh saying
something
goes the dudes with the arms and the
hair well yeah see that's what i always
the dudes with the r the dude with the
arm
no it's like well this is a joke of what
and i've joked with you about this
before but it's like this joke goes all
the way back to like my high school
years because me and my friends be like
we'd be talking about somebody that we
both knew or a dude that was in a movie
or something like that
and we would not be able to remember
their name and so we were trying to
describe them but we weren't very good
at describing them
you know what i mean you know that guy
and then the other person
would be like the dude with the eyes you
know and the head
he was like you were not helping
that's what i mean it's just like like
you're not helping because you're not
describing anything
that's all that significant yeah but
yeah
freddie mercury was in commando yeah so
you might as well have been
um but yeah did path kitty come back yes
i saw him
on monday and then i didn't see him
yesterday
and so i was kind of like uh-oh and then
i saw him
this morning interestingly i'm not sure
if somebody else has been like i know
other people in the past like feed him
because i've seen that happen
but like i said he had like some kind of
sore like on his side and i think it
might be where
he pulled that hair mat off and so it
was bleeding and so i bought
some of that um it's like an antibiotic
spray and you like spray it it's like
you know it's topical and it's safe for
them to lick because he doesn't have
like the you know
the cone of shame or anything because
he's an outsider yet
yeah that has a name but it's just cone
of shame hi tila thank you
tila jumps in sending money our way
thank you very much j t
thanks for introducing me to videodrome
what a great and trippy
movie okay you got to see that one
fantastic yeah
and the the whole dude he had his whole
manifesto on videotape he would speak to
you through
the television the television is like an
eye
directly to the mind yeah that's the
[ __ ] creepy [ __ ] man
yeah i love that imagine seeing that
[ __ ] when you were like uh well what
year did that come out
was that 81 okay i thought it was 81
maybe it was later
now i can't remember so i might have
been around 11 or 12 when i saw it
i was [ __ ] tripping yeah yeah maybe
13.
it's a good movie yeah he's down there
brainwashing the bums with the [ __ ]
cathode raid tube
the cathode ray tube eye yeah and they
had the damn
cable 83 it was sorry i was waiting 83
said it was
14 or 14 or 15 when i saw it
oh yeah this [ __ ] is [ __ ] trip so
and then they had the damn snm [ __ ]
torture channel
coming through the damn satellite
television [ __ ] that was some wild
[ __ ] the whole the whole concept of a
[ __ ] satellite tv was a trip to me
too
well yeah it's funny because nowadays
yeah like you could talk to
t they had some people that had radar
dishes satellite dishes outside their
house
even in heidelberg mississippi they had
them it's funny you see these little
[ __ ] country houses a big old [ __ ]
satellite dish out there
it's funny because i was thinking about
this kind of like the other day
because oh you know why because i was
listening to my pandora station while i
was out hiking and that song mexican
radio came on by walla voodoo
and then i was thinking to myself how
funny like that song came out in 82 or
83
and i was like how big a deal that was
to like get broadcasts from other
countries and stuff and now it's like
nothing
but um you know she says would y'all
remake it oh absolutely not
absolutely not i just don't think it
would have worked i don't think it would
work the same
remake what uh video drums no no
i i think it's it's a product of the
time
yeah and um you know and the thing about
it is david cronenberg's son is making
like cool ass movies
nowadays yeah along the same line so
that [ __ ] only worked in the time in the
day
because video was such a new technology
and new video products
were being sold to you in the form of
cable television
satellite television and vhs and some
people actually could afford a vhs
camera damn those they were [ __ ]
expensive back to you
if you had that and
because these were new emerging
technologies
there's always a possibility that there
might be some bad
side effects to that and that's what
that movie was about
watching imagery might [ __ ] your mind up
now we know it's maybe only partially
true depends on what's in that imagery
yeah because you can pop you can put out
misinformation disinformation
uh [ __ ] propaganda you can change
people's opinions and force opinions on
people
mass psychology but they're talking
about on an individual level through an
underground
channel showing you weird [ __ ] like
perverse torture porn and in it is a
damn [ __ ]
it's a carrier for a signal that can go
into your brain
and alter your biology or maybe
or are you just going crazy you don't
know
you know you don't know because he his
he grabbed a gun and his hand engulfed
that gun then he put that gun in his
belly and then later on was
used as like a manchurian candidate an
assassin
to go out and he pulled that gun out of
his belly killed a guy with it and he
put the gun back didn't he
then somebody else punched him in the
stomach where the gun was when he pulled
his head out his head was now a [ __ ]
ticking time bomb a grenade so he had
no what did he really have mastery over
his own
body was he the thing like the thing now
or was it all in his mind
was he crazy well it could be either
thing could be either one you don't know
man imagine how handy that would be if
you could just store everything in your
stomach didn't have to carry a purse
no that's but that's more relevant for
you you didn't need to carry a concealed
permit you didn't need a holster you
just put the gun in your stomach
it's like hey let me get my lipstick my
phone and my wallet [ __ ] like that
yeah somebody said possessor was coming
to shutter we saw it on
amazon prime i think because we reviewed
that a little while and also
i did i did a review of anti-viral which
was brandon cronenberg's first movie
and i watched that on uk shutter i don't
think it's on american shutter
but it might be they might add possessor
and antiviral at the same time
um but yeah oh what i was saying about
path kitty
whose name is maguire his name is mr
maguire so
he so i so i had sprayed like some of
that topical uh stuff on him
on monday and then tuesday i didn't see
him
so i was kind of like well [ __ ] where
did he go but i saw him this morning
and it looks like somebody that kind of
knew what they were doing
like cut the mats out of his hair
because on one side the matte
the hair mat's completely gone the other
side it's gone but a lot of his hair is
just down to the skin but it had to
because it got like torn off you know
what i mean
now where the blood was there's like a
cut
or some kind of something so it's like
this big kind of cut on his side
but it wasn't bleeding today but i
couldn't tell if it was scabbed over or
if had stitches
um but it didn't seem to be bothering
him like i took my other glove out and i
was like
you know combing his hair and honestly i
got so much [ __ ] hair out of that cat
it was like a tennis ball like it was
this
big like what came out on the glove and
um
so i put some more spray on the cut and
he didn't seem to be it didn't seem to
be hurting him or anything but it's not
bleeding anymore so maybe it's getting
better
yeah what else is it if you if you saw a
video drum
you saw you saw the brood right i think
she did i
really like i really liked the brain the
brood was good too
rick shaw says i need alcohol yeah don't
we all
um camp guy said it's not as good as
clove hitch killer i you know what
i just watched clove hitch killer
yesterday and did a review of it which
is going up
and uh i don't even remember when it's
going up in a week or two
something like that um what's on uk
shutter
antiviral uh brandon cronenberg's first
movie possessor might be on there too i
haven't actually checked it in a little
while
we saw that one do we uh i saw antiviral
you didn't see it i didn't see it we saw
a possessor possessed right yeah that's
it was pretty good
yeah i liked possessor anti-viral was
weird i think i liked possessor a little
bit better but anti-viral was still
really good too
i mean picture says ew clove hitch was
garbage i really liked it i liked it
i could so it's weird it was one of
those movies where people either really
dug it or they really hate it i think a
lot of people hated it because they
didn't like the end
but i but i didn't i wasn't bothered by
the end actually
it kind of made sense to me t says she
saw the brood a long time ago about the
hybrid children
the question mark it's they're not
hybrid children it's
go see it again go see it again you'll
like it after seeing video drum you'll
probably you'll probably appreciate it
uh more cronenberg's into this body
horror and the idea that
institutions can do bad things he likes
that i like that too
it's about a dude who has
come up with uh a way of [ __ ]
like it's kind of like a self-help
program using like
like a types of meditation
and it's a lot he's trying to find
a way so people can
take their inner traumas and kind of
like move them to the outside
to where they can manage them and deal
with them
and it doesn't work all the time but
it does bad [ __ ] to certain people and
and in one particular woman she it
gives her the ability to give birth to
children just on her own
it's [ __ ] weird man they're like rage
me yeah
yeah they're like rage monsters because
they're not real they're they're
like they're children but not really
they're kind of chill yeah
they're mutant children well because i
mean connected to her
it's like immaculate conception yeah but
they're not really
humans no i mean they are but they're
more like a clown
yeah like an evil clown and she just
produces them from her
negative emotions they're like drones
too they're sexless
and she's kind of psychically connected
to them
or was it pheromones like i think it
might be [ __ ] no i can't i think it
might have been pheromones kind of like
a queen ant
i think yeah it was that kind of
something like that yeah
weird taylor said she watched the ninth
gate which was a roman polanski movie
i've actually been wanting to do that
because they have it on hulu
and i've put it in the poll uh a couple
times but it never wins
so maybe we'll just do it anyway just
for the hell of it
what's another cronenberg movie that's
that's uh like like the
uh shivers yeah that one's okay
um there was bad he made better ones
than that well that was an early one
yeah that was the one about the sex
parasite it's around the time of video
drama i think after that
what came out after that scanners
scanners
that's right although no i think
scanners was maybe before before
if you haven't seen scanners see
scanners we need a review scanner
yeah see david june says ninth gate is
awesome see i remember i think i saw a
ninth gate in the theater
and i remember it being really good but
i haven't seen it since then
so i saw that it was on hulu and i was
like oh we should probably review that
maybe we could just do it as a matinee
one day because i've been wanting to
watch it again
yeah the fly was good but the fly was a
mainstream movie
still great though yeah it didn't really
feel like a [ __ ] weird
underground dirty cronenberg movie
though and that's what his movies kind
of dirty yeah they were kind of they
needed
they did they made you feel like you
needed to take a shower afterwards
like you weren't really supposed to be
watching that at least when i was a kid
well see that was the best thing about
all the kind of
movies back then i mean nowadays i i
feel like it doesn't have
the same uh allure to it like so much
out there because there's so much out
there and it's like yeah you know but
like back then it was kind of like
everybody would talk about you've seen
them
yeah you're like yeah that's just
terrible did you see it yeah
that's just nasty yeah yeah it's
you know just because there wasn't as
much stuff out there and
you had cable tv and you didn't have to
pay for it you could just wait for it to
come back on again
and cable was our version of the
internet back in those days
and everybody was watching it and dead
zone he did dead zone
yeah dead zone but that's another one it
was mainstream
because it was it's not a stephen king
yeah he did
he did christine too didn't he yeah that
was john carpenter
that was john carpenter yeah uh but
david croninberg did make a
movie called crash which was based on a
jg ballard
uh story did you see crash no
oh it was it was about the people that
were like erratically
attracted to car crashes yeah i heard
about it yeah
i think i saw that in the theater it was
like 96 right 94.96
somewhere might have been later and then
he made um existence
yeah which was kind of about like a
virtual reality video game but like i
remember all the all the games like it
plugged
into your it was like an organic video
game like it plugged right into your
like an umbilical cord like it plugged
right into your spinal column and
all the the controller for the video
game was like
made of flesh and you had to like
massage it to get it to do [ __ ] and
stuff like that
hey tila add scanners on there too
scanner's one
scanner's two is [ __ ] i i remember
scanner two as being good but i was a
kid when i saw it
went back and saw it later because
cronenberg didn't do that somebody else
did
scanners too is [ __ ] unwatchable but
scanners one with
scanners is [ __ ] great rabid that was
the one i was trying to think of yeah
rabbit yeah that's right
that one was okay i still would take
scanners over over
scanners was up there with like video
dro
and the brood it was like that i love
that uh that the head explosion from
scanners has just become a meme
yeah you know what i mean like every
time you want to show that you just
somebody blew your mind you just brushed
that's such a great effect scanners was
about a company
they were government contractor weren't
they
yeah i think i haven't seen it in a
while but yeah and they had uh figured
out how to
either breed people or get people to
have psychic
abilities like telekinesis yeah but it
was mostly about
getting you could look at a person and
you could kill a person with
thought i think they could get you to do
things though too can they
yes they just kill you they can suggest
things to you yeah i think they could
although i might be mixing it up with
fire starter
right because remember the dad and fire
starter had that ability to like yeah
push people so he could get him to do
whatever they were going to use them as
kind of like
assassins of course one of them goes
rogue
that's a pretty good movie a couple of
them go rogue actually yeah
doing [ __ ] on their own pat said don't
forget they came from within yeah it's
that's called shivers over here for
whatever reason um
but yeah that's the same movie shivers
was funded by the canadian government
i think a lot of his movies were because
they had that like tax shelter
like don't you guys watch fantasy movies
lord of the rings harry potter
maleficent etc yeah um
i liked the lord of the rings ones i
liked uh the harry potter movies
although i liked the books better um i
don't know for whatever reason
i like some of them but it's not like a
big genre for me i don't really like
um real big spectacle movies as a rule
um there are exceptions to that rule
obviously but
even like kind of the marvel movies and
stuff like that
like i like them but it's not i don't
really like seek them out you know what
i'm saying i like to
conan that's about it for fantasy which
is yeah
and that's not like way over-the-top
fantasy that's kind of like
conan one [ __ ] conan the destroyer was
okay
it wasn't as good as the first one you
know milius john millions wasn't
involved in that one
um i wish they they would have made
millions original trilogy
destroyer though in a weird way was
closer to the [ __ ] conan comic books
though
yeah they had some terrible special
effects it really
there's a two or three scenes where
they're fighting boss monsters
if they could redo those scenes using
some kind of uh
cgi or cg insert
different combat scenes in there that
movie would be a lot better
because it's really only two scenes in
it that [ __ ] the movie up
fighting the wizard around all those
mirrors and the final boss monster was
[ __ ]
pretty cheesy yeah the rest of it wasn't
that bad
you could fix it just i don't know fix
it
[Laughter]
well the rest of the movie wasn't that
bad yeah it wasn't it was just spoiled
by those
those costumes yeah i kind of feel like
you're going to cheap out on that shitty
they're just like don't put it in them
don't put it in because it's just going
to like ruin it yeah
you know what i mean uh tila said i also
re-watched the howling one of the best
werewolf movies
yeah ever oh yeah the first one yeah
uh yeah donald trump that's like a
female i thought that female
uh a werewolf when i was a kid i thought
that [ __ ] girl was hot as [ __ ] man
were you were you like i have the
weirdest boner right now yeah
yeah she's kind of she's an animal but
no
no when she wasn't turned into oh okay
so she did a bunch of nude scenes and
[ __ ] shoot that that girl was [ __ ]
she went i'm trying to say she was a
girl she's a girl now compared to me now
but
she was probably 25 she was [ __ ] hot
yeah yeah
like 13 you're going oh god i wish i
could get that
[Laughter]
you know you can tell you got your
injection today
no that's the way it was that's the way
it was
oh my gosh the way it was and look man
grab this is gonna [ __ ] back me up
[ __ ] we're from the same generation
that's the way we thought back then
you're 13. you're just looking at the
screen going well i think i think that's
how
that's the way all the guys were yeah
the way most they're gonna be honest
about it
and be honest about it yeah sheila
anne's also so there's another
vote for the ninth gate [ __ ] man we
should probably do that i'm gonna write
it down
i have it because like i said i put it
in the poll a couple times and it never
wins
and i was like i've been wanting to
rewatch it ever since i saw that hulu
added it
and i was like well [ __ ] man maybe we
could just do a matinee on it then
nobody has to vote on it we'll just do
it
thank you zach even tila said that was a
great sex scene in the howling with that
yeah it was she was hot he had sexy lips
and she was kind of gothic she had but
she was kind of like hippie gothic
she had the long black hair parted in
the middle yeah wearing the kind of like
black kind of see-through gauzy looking
material
and [ __ ] real low-cut [ __ ] like a
v thing and she's running around she's
kind of like a biker looking
too you know she's just she's [ __ ]
hot you know
[ __ ] pouty lips and [ __ ] pouty
lipsticks
bee stung lips howdy yeah look like yeah
you just got her botox injection
yeah like angelina jolie yeah uh thank
you zach he said and i had an idea for a
cronenberg style pandemic themed horror
movie about a guy hallucinating his body
falling apart in isolation
uh yeah i'm sure we'll probably be
seeing uh
some movies like that coming out i've
already seen like some ones that were
that were made about that if you can
like knock them out esther says uh the
history of lips and boobs by tom ross
thank you very much write a whole
whole book about it yeah he's gonna
write a book about it you did right you
did read off zach's uh
i did yeah okay what were you not paying
attention no i hadn't i just i had to
read he
had read i had to read i can't read and
listen at the same time pat
pat hatfield said the same thing i agree
with your thoughts on the howling
tila also agree with the female werewolf
being ultra hot yeah that's what we're
talking about
hot werewolf
[Laughter]
oh my god there's another shirt when she
turned into the werewolf she just looked
like a werewolf but when she was
in human form she was hot as [ __ ] you
want me i got pictures to prove it okay
okay um so what if she still kind of
looked like a human but then kind of
looked like a werewolf and
also had like six boobs would that still
be hot or would it be starting to get
into weird territory
i guess it depends he did kind look like
that as a werewolf
yeah that's what i'm saying it shouldn't
look hot though you could just tell she
was
you could just tell she's like she needs
them there i just can't you could just
tell it was supposed to be her
yeah you know but no we did a review on
that [ __ ]
kind of a dog yeah i think she had boobs
but it didn't matter you know what i
mean she looked like a bipedal dog
walking around big old [ __ ] fangs
[Laughter]
which i guess is some guy's dream girl
just saying i don't know there might be
there might be some
oh i'm sure there's some [ __ ] fetish
porn for that uh
well it's fast part for everything there
is that's what i mean that's that's what
i call internet rule 34.
anything you can think of there's porn
of it yeah that's the rule
um yeah zach says also did you guys hear
about amazon buying mgm
i heard about it yeah um
okay amazon's dumb as [ __ ] for buying
mgm mgm's going broke as hell
um what do they want 007
that james bond movie [ __ ] sucks
they're gonna have to reshoot that thing
again
i i wouldn't have bought it i would let
[ __ ] mgm [ __ ] go belly up
but they want that catalog well that's
what i mean that's probably why they
bought it so they can have the catalog
because it's probably a massive back
catalog yeah there's just not much there
though i heard it all listed off of what
they might be interested in and
mgm tried to launch some of those
properties and they didn't launch
they tried to launch [ __ ] mcchucky
that didn't work they tried to launch a
bunch of that [ __ ] it didn't work
these are [ __ ] suits all right suits
are not creative
they see these properties as platforms
of just making money they don't see
anything about creativity
thank you again mr roboto
once you start you don't think about it
really some dude he's talking about the
howling
okay yeah um they're going to end up
with a bunch of loser properties that
nobody wants to watch
the reason why nobody watches this book
that [ __ ] anymore
because it's not new it's not fresh you
can't reboot these [ __ ] things over
and over again
you can't just inject a bunch of [ __ ]
identity politics and a bunch of [ __ ]
trans
transsectional [ __ ] in there and get
it to work
you have to make new [ __ ] and they don't
want to hear that
it's too risky for them even though
they're going to realize that these old
properties are [ __ ] losers
all right they can't even get [ __ ]
terminator right
you know anything they do is going to
[ __ ] suck it's because they're just
they're just a bunch of suits
they're not artists think about it
foreign all these [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] big
properties they were not made by suits
part one was always made by some little
independent guy who was just i'm gonna
do this oh wow look at that never been
done before
and it took off
you can't just revamp and rehash over
and over again people will
they don't care but like i said i
understand why they do it they've been
doing that
since [ __ ] movies started yeah back
in the [ __ ] early 20th century why
they're going out of business right now
i mean you know it works for a while and
like i said yeah diminishing returns
yeah you know it's just kind of like
you know people like things that are
familiar um but only up to a point
but the thing about it is that nobody
really knows
you know and if they thank you no need
for me
um nobody really knows like what
anyone's gonna like even people that say
they know what people are gonna like
they don't know what people are gonna
like you never know what's gonna hit
right
so i kind of feel like if you try to
make something that's gonna be a big hit
it's just you're gonna like
i don't know how many times have we done
[ __ ] movie reviews where
people were like i mean [ __ ] man even
george lucas when he did star wars
he's like yeah i didn't really think it
was gonna go anywhere look how that
[ __ ] worked out
i don't think that anybody really
can predict like how like what's gonna
hit and what's not
because some things i've seen some
movies that
you know they supposedly did everything
right
and they had everything well this is
what everybody likes this is this that
and the other thing
and what oh that's the girl from now
we're just proving it right now we're
going to prove it
hey that's a girl from
howard yeah yeah um
yeah you're going to read his uh yeah
he said down with that the super chat
what said um
it was from no need for me down with
identity politics and entertainment yeah
it's just [ __ ] old
you can see right through it and it just
it's not artistic
it's just some corporate [ __ ]
they're checking little boxes
and they're going to come up with some
generic [ __ ] it ends up being like
art from a from like a soviet union you
know what i mean
soviet union couldn't make art because
it all had to apply to a certain [ __ ]
soviet ideal
and so there's no creativity and nothing
spontaneous everything was artificial
it's just gonna be generic
well like i said because they're trying
to appeal to the widest possible
audience yeah if you're trying to do
that
it's like you've now [ __ ] it up yeah
because then it's going to be like
people that are really into it aren't
going to be into it's like you know
whatever
you can't please everybody art is
spontaneous it's hit or miss
and sometimes it hits a lot of times it
misses when uh art usually hits
a lot of the [ __ ] that doesn't make any
money in the in the film business it
wasn't art to begin with
it was just some [ __ ] that they
could it's been tinkered with yeah
and i'm not saying i mean because
sometimes you know we did a review the
other day of like
close encounters and stuff like that
where it was originally one person's
vision but then it got [ __ ] with and
tinkered with and stuff but sometimes
when that happens
it still comes out good like but that's
pretty rare it's rare i think the more
it gets [ __ ] with
like the the farther it strays away from
the original vision
uh the shittier it's not always because
sometimes
it depends on who had the original
vision because sometimes the person that
had the original vision
needs an editor you know what i mean um
so
and and if they're just kind of left to
their own devices and like
they do their own thing you know case in
point i mean you know i know it's easy
to like say like george lucas like it's
good that he had other people like
saying hey don't do that because that's
dumb
but the same thing applies to people
like you know stephen king
where when he tries to make a movie um
he you know when you can see it between
like the stanley kubrick version of the
shining
and stephen king's version of the
shining obviously the stanley kubrick
one is a million times better
um but stephen king thought that
he thinks that his one is better even
though it is clearly not
even though he's clearly wrong but you
know what i mean thank you again mr
roboto
idea frankenstein takes hollywood we can
make it
frankenstein or frankenstein's monster
esther says i couldn't finish auditions
scared the hell out of me i'm going to
do
that on my flickr's affair show
eventually it's on my
list and tila was also talking about
watching tenebre which is another one
i'm gonna do
uh the one i'm doing next well no
because i do them ahead
but i'm doing uh the church by uh
michele sawavi the same guy that
directed a cemetery man
it was like produced and written by
dario argento as well
um kind of a later one i think it was
like late 80s ozzy argento was in it
when she was kind of a kid or a teenager
and uh so i've been watching that one
i've seen it before but i'm like
re-watching it to do a review
best channel right now about film and
hollywood
if you ask me is on youtube i'm gonna
give him a plug it's a youtube channel
called midnight's edge and i think the
guy who
who actually runs the channel i think
he's from sweden or norway denmark
something like that
but there's a bunch of american guys and
there's people that were directors in
hollywood some of them are kind of like
hollywood outcasts
people that some of them are still in
hollywood and
they know the lingo and the business and
they'll tell you what certain things
mean and why they're doing certain
things and how the studio systems all
work
and it's going just the way i said it
was and mostly because i've been
listening to those dudes for years too
so i saw it coming
they're consolidated hollywood is hasn't
really made
the kind of money that that the
investors
wanted to make and what they've been
normally making especially in past
decades
it's taken about 15 years for it to get
to where it is now
okay um the studio system is very
bloated very inefficient
very corrupt the budgets do not really
reflect how much actually went into the
movie
a lot of is greasing palms hiding money
tax sheltering tax evasion um
lots and lots of corruption sending
money to your cousin
hiring your cousin to play a certain
part
just because you know they're trying to
keep the monies within
the empires and the families not about
writing
it's not really about talent more about
product placement
more about donations from political
groups it's just a bloated
[ __ ] mess and then this
then the the theater chains were
involved in it
coveted was you kind of used as a
partial excuse to collapse all that
because they weren't making money they
want to sell all this stuff up to to the
next generation
and that's going to be silicon valley
and silicon valley
part two in silicon valley part three
and it's gonna be those streaming
services
and that's where it's gonna go the good
part about it is that some of these
streaming services
will be able to fund very small prop
projects or buy very small projects
so there's going to be a very vibrant
indie film
industry and that's really what we need
to be looking at if you want to look at
indie film all right there's some good
news
disney's getting its act together
they're gonna [ __ ] make
star wars a for-profit [ __ ] business
and they're gonna put [ __ ] the the
guys that did the mandalorian are gonna
basically handle the entire
brand okay so it's all going to be good
as [ __ ]
as good as mandalorian was if not better
because
they're getting rid of all the people
that had different agendas it's just
going to be a for-profit
business another good thing
that they're talking about is that conan
is safe
the guy in the howard foundation who
owns the rights to conan
has made sure that the marvel comic book
of conan
is legit comic books [ __ ] suck
especially marvel
right now with the exception of a couple
of brands and one of them is [ __ ]
conan they say conan is great
and they said if you give a [ __ ] about
comic books or any of this stuff
by conan is supported i wouldn't mind
getting some conan comic books and read
how that's going
but the movies writes for codename
amazon tried to buy it but when the guy
who owns the
howard foundation saw the script he's
like nope nope nope that's not true to
the books
and he said no to them because the
dude's got money he doesn't give a [ __ ]
so he's not gonna pimp conan out like a
cheap [ __ ]
conan movies from the future will be
conan movies
he the guy who runs the foundation liked
conan one even though he said that
wasn't totally accurate
he still liked the vibe of that and
that's going to be the conan this guy
will not sell out if
because the way new technologies are
going
if interest is there he theoretically
could do kickstarters and raise enough
money to do the movies without any
studio help
and do all that [ __ ] contracted all by
the fans
and you would get a badass [ __ ] conan
movies or a series
just like the way mst is doing remember
mst
mft they want netflix wanted to [ __ ]
with mst you know and then they didn't
want to pay a certain amount of money
mst said [ __ ] netflix
we we have our own fan base we can raise
our own money
and make the show without any eu studios
or
[ __ ] all and they got exactly what they
wanted and more and how long
tell them how that kick started well it
was 30 days they got 6.5 million
which was more than what they actually
needed to do this
to do a season and she contributed jenny
contributed
yeah i gave him money hell yeah yeah and
that's going to be the model of the
future
i mean they they're building uh their
own virtual theater
that's going to have an app uh they're
going to do i think 12 or 13
episodes so they're doing a whole like
full season and they got like a bunch of
shorts they're going to do i think
they're going to do a dozen shorts like
separately
and they're going to have all kind of
guest stars they're going to have all
kind of [ __ ] it's going to be super cool
so they're going to be able to make them
the series that they wanted to make for
their specific fans
nobody meddling into the product that's
the model of the future
that's [ __ ] great because the problem
with the old way was is you had studios
and then you had um producers who would
[ __ ] flip up
and investors they would put forth all
this money on these projects and then
they would dictate to the directors and
the writers
no i don't want that in my movie i'm not
gonna pay for that so you don't want
them in there
because that doesn't have anything to do
with the fans you
want the pr you want the producers and
the investors to be the fans themselves
to prepay for these [ __ ]
that's where you go that's the way to go
that way the fans will get the movie
that they paid for
yeah that's the way it should be it's
for the fans
yeah not the studios so zack asked me a
question a long time ago
um was there anything that i saw like a
a movie that i saw that i liked better
than the book
the first thing that i thought of
actually the only thing that i thought
of
was the hunger the hunger was written by
whitley strieber
the same guy that uh got um
kidnapped by aliens and wrote communion
probably his better known book
but he wrote the hunger as well and then
they made a movie about it in 1983 which
we reviewed uh catherine denove david
bowie
susan sarandon and i saw the movie first
and i loved it it's like a goth wet
dream i love that [ __ ] movie and i've
seen it over and over i know
some people at the time complained oh
blah blah it looks like a video music
video with style over says
[ __ ] those people it's an awesome
awesome movie
so then like i read the book after i saw
and i liked the book
but it wasn't it didn't give me the same
i don't know like i just really really
liked the whole like
vibe of the movie and i didn't really
get that from the book as much the book
is still good
and the only thing i liked better about
the book that it is that it goes into
miriam's
kind of backstory a lot more which they
kind of refer to in the movie like
there's a couple little flashbacks like
oh she was in ancient egypt and all this
other kind of stuff
they go more into that in the book um
and i liked that
but it they didn't really need that for
the movie because it really wasn't all
that relevant
just to show yeah she's super [ __ ]
old like she's been around forever
um but that's kind of the only thing i
think i'm sure there's something else
i mean [ __ ] man now i can't think but
i mean almost always 99.99 percent of
the time the book is always going to be
better
but i don't know that's the only one
that i could think of that was the first
one that like popped into my head was
the hunger because i remember reading
the book and like being like man i liked
the movie better
that doesn't usually happen though it's
weird because sometimes if i've
read the book before i go see the movie
it seems like the movie is going like
super fast because they have to leave so
much [ __ ]
out of the book and i'm like oh my god
this shit's happening already so
i don't know it's really weird i don't i
like to see movie adaptations
of books that i've read but in a way i
kind of don't because
i understand it's two different mediums
but i don't know sometimes it seems like
i watched the movie and it just seems
like they left so much out
and [ __ ] just happened so fast i kind of
felt that about the harry potter movies
too although i liked
i didn't love the first couple harry
potter movies because it was still like
you know kid focused they got better as
they got
you know as they went along because the
kids got older and like the stories were
scarier and [ __ ] like that
so you know i liked the books as they
went along better as well
but the ride is great well that
whole like universal [ __ ] well they
built the whole entire
i mean they built like a whole the
wizarding world of harry potter it looks
amazing like the [ __ ] they have
diagon alley and
all the shops you can buy butter beer
and all the [ __ ] [ __ ] it's great you
get on this broomstick
right and you fly around this broomstick
it's it's virtu it's partially virtual
reality
part of it you really are moving and it
just feels like a 360 degree view of
flying around this goddamn broomstick
the wind blasting by you
i felt like i was on a roller coaster i
mean i i really bought the motion it
felt like it was [ __ ] moving
it's not moving as fast as you think it
is but it but it feels like it feels
like it is well they're pretty good at
doing that nowadays it was on that damn
broom stick
and it [ __ ] goes way up in the air
when the wind's blowing by and then it
dips down and you see the damn school
and you were diving down kind of with
the wind going and spray
from mist it felt like uh felt like you
were flying uh flying down at about 180
knots nah
120 knots felt fast if you get motion
sickness i'm
not advised going on you know i'm
x [ __ ] hundred first air airborne
with [ __ ] 506. we used to fly around
with the choppers with the doors open
[ __ ] hanging out with the m60s and
[ __ ]
and yeah i was fooled it felt like we
were
like i was flying on a goddamn
broomstick and that's universal
goddamn on a goddamn broomstick
brimstick
sabrina asked if i had read the sequel
to the hunger no i have not
i haven't read a lot of wheatley street
i read the hunger and i read communion
it's all about how good the hunger is
it's a good vampire movie real good
and tila was saying how much she liked
that necklace that miriam used that
that had the blade that came out i love
that movie i'm not and somebody said it
was a guilty pleasure i'm not guilty
about it i love that [ __ ] movie
no it started off with [ __ ] uh the
guys from baja [ __ ] bauhaus was in
there
bella goats he's dead and [ __ ] yeah
white on white
translucent black i mean i just loved
like i said it's just
man yeah it was just when i was when i
was a little goth and like junior high
in high school
man we had all had seen that vhs yeah
because everybody's like there's this
movie that's like a vampire
there's like all this [ __ ] and it's so
cool and there's that weird angle that
yeah you live forever but you up to a
certain point and then you just start
aging
and then you start disintegrating but
you're still alive yeah
and i was like if you think about it i'm
like wow that's horrible and like she
[ __ ] keeps them all
like up in the attic yeah for some
strange reason she can't bring herself
to kill you
so she just leaves you alive because she
loves them
yeah it leaves you but she's also a
monster yeah
i mean i think that's why it was really
good like because she was
she was a very interesting villain
because
i mean obviously she was a villain but
you could kind of sympathize with her
too she just she couldn't
she wanted somebody that was going to be
with her forever like a companion
and her blood and human blood just
didn't really mix
and she kept having these problems it's
like 200 300 years down the line
you know their her companion would start
aging and she'd be like oh [ __ ]
but you know she should have obviously
told them like before because of course
she like hyped it all up like yeah you
live forever
but she didn't tell you that you weren't
young forever like you were you were
young for a long time
but then you started to age like super
rapidly and then you started to rot
essentially and then she'd be like okay
i'm putting you up in a cap
in a coffin in the attic by and then
you'd be up there like [ __ ]
disintegrating
and you'd still be alive i'm like oh my
god that's so [ __ ] horrifying
i mean the implications of it are
horrifying yeah
you sympathize with bowie's characters
too the sad aging process you went
through yeah
yeah you know you got it still uh
t you still gotta see um a clockwork
orange
and and then after that you gotta see i
thought she said she'd seen that
after that you to see um uh
bronson i don't think she saw clockwork
you saw it a long time ago
yeah yeah sheila anne said i love the
hunger i wanted that classical piece
played at my wedding yeah that's a
beautiful
uh piece of music what it's uh [ __ ] man
not franz list who would do it [ __ ] man
i can't remember what it was i'll think
of it in a minute
i'll think of it in a minute i know who
it is i have it
somewhere i just don't remember who it
is
but it's got that opera [ __ ] in it too
he didn't forget that bowie could act
yeah i wanted to do um another movie i
wanted to do was
um the bandit fell to earth yeah which
i think is on hulu i think i saw they
added it the other day so i want to do
that
and he was also in have you guys ever
seen a movie called the linguine
incident
yeah he was he played the bartender in
that didn't he yeah from the 80s like
rosanna or cat was in it it was kind of
a rom-com
a little bit but it was kind of like a
quirky i don't even want to say rom-com
it was kind of like a rom-com
but in the way that sort of desperately
seeking susan was a rom-com
it was that kind of vibe to it um but i
have like an
unashamed love of that movie and i feel
like a lot of people haven't seen it i
saw it like a million times i don't know
vhs like back in the day
i liked a lot of a lot of bowie's stuff
that was kind of like
off the beaten path like some of his
albums that weren't
that popular i [ __ ] loved them like
the bowie album tonight
yeah they had blue jean on it yeah and
[ __ ] loving the alien and all that
kind of [ __ ]
and that's like for some reason people
don't really like that album but i like
that album a lot there's
yeah it was kind of a romantic sounding
album
you know it was yeah not really the same
as say let's dance i think it was that
was the album that came after let's
dance but i [ __ ] loved it i just
loved that
yeah i'm pretty sure or it was not that
really good albums
really good uh lyrics on that album
looking um
loving the alien and uh [ __ ]
what else is on that you know what i
don't
i don't think i have that up i have
let's dance i had most of the ones
before that
but i don't know i went this morning to
the cemetery
to see old rudy valentino buried
lipstick traces on his name he never
looked down
they were making crazy sounds
sounds from central park to shantytown
remember that one yeah yeah i always
heard that crazy sound
do you guys remember absolute beginners
yeah yeah that's
actually that song is on yeah well that
was something
that was an ep yeah yeah like because he
did some of that he was in that as well
i think
i just saw that one time like a long
time ago dj maniac said the linguine
incident was on e all the time
yeah i just for some reason i really
really there's something really charming
about that movie
it's like i i still remember lines from
it i still remember
rosanna arquette i can't remember what
the uh what the situation was
but where she got like was she tied up
in her house or she couldn't move or
something like that and he came in like
untied or whatever and she said
something like
i got a piss like a racehorse or
something and then i remember her saying
talking to her friend because when she
first starts banging david bowie
she says you know perfectly well new sex
is like crack
last time i had a new boyfriend or
something like that i i had so many
library books overdue that they took
away my card or something like that
and it's just like i don't know there's
something like really really charming
about that movie it is kind of like a
rom-com but
you know not not like a rom-com nowadays
like you'd see
yeah hallmark channel or whatever i was
in my 20s when i saw it i liked it
yeah it's good i'd have to like watch it
again i saw it a bunch of times
when i was younger but um
it's really i don't even remember how i
ended up watching it i probably just saw
it on cable and i was like oh david
bowie's in this that's for me
and um and i feel like nobody really
talks about it anymore there's kind of
movies like that that sort of fall
through the cracks
i feel like that one and another one
that i was thinking of the other day
because i was going back through some
movies
that i wanted to do for my show so i was
making like making a list
and i ended up doing the reflecting skin
which for a long time
i thought i was the only person that had
seen that movie like i thought maybe i'd
imagined it but then like when i put the
review up like some people like oh my
god i can't believe you did this one
because it's like i remember this weird
ass [ __ ]
yeah it's one of the weirdest movies
ever there was another one
called closet land and alan rickman was
in it
and madeline stowe i want to say
and basically i think the two of them
were the only people in it
it was almost kind of like a stage play
but it was a movie
you know what i'm saying yeah and it had
something to do it reminded me a little
bit of
[ __ ] man what was that movie with nicole
kidman dog bill
that was kind of like a stage play where
all the houses were like tape like on
the ground or whatever
it kind of reminded me of that but it
came out like back in 1991
something and i saw it on cable and i
really liked it
and uh i think madeleine stowe was like
a children's book author or something
and there was like some kind of trauma
in her past or whatever
and he was supposed to be like her
psychologist i want to say and then he
was like trying to get all this stuff
out of her
but it was just like it was real weird
and i remember
taping it and i watched it a bunch of
times and i have never heard anybody
mention that movie
since then sheila anne comes up with a
good one a lot of people forgot she said
her parents saw
david bowie play the elephant man on
broadway
yeah wow i forgot he did that yeah a lot
of people you know
think that bowie was just a rock star he
was not a rock star he was an
entertainer he saw himself as an
entertainer and what he really wanted to
be was an actor
yeah um he was in the [ __ ] son of movies
yeah when
twin peaks in the 70s when he's doing
rock stars [ __ ] he's singing about
his fantasies of being an actor but he
was kind of a little bit of everything
kind of like sammy davis junior
he could sing he could dance he could
have it was like a wrench he was an
entertainer
right sheila ann says willem dafoe shows
up in the hunger too he does indeed he
shows up he's like a guy that's uh
comes up to the phone booth while
somebody else is using the phone booth
like he wants to see his phone and
that's like i don't know if that was his
first movie but yeah i was like hey
william
there you go yeah renaissance man that's
what he was
um yeah tila said uh he was on broadway
wow an amazing life yeah yeah he also
predicted the impact of the internet i
remember it
back in the mid to late 90s when he came
out when he
gave a speech he did an interview and he
says people don't realize
what this means you know we came from a
time when there was just one truth
and there was one lie you were told this
through the television
now everyone has their own truth and
their own lies because this
will totally everyone will be living in
their own world
and this is just how it's going to be
this is how it's evolving and that's
really the way
that has the internet really has done
that
to the world not just american society
everybody
it's a network society it's not a
top-down civilization where you have
an authoritarian structure saying this
is what you will watch
this is what you will wear this is what
you will believe i mean they're trying
but it's not working
well uh you know i mean we've talked
about this before i'm like really really
happy that you can just pretty much
you can live your own life do well you
can do what you want to do like i said i
can design my [ __ ] board games i can
write my books i can do all that kind of
[ __ ] and i can just do everything from
my house and like not have to like deal
with anybody else's [ __ ] about it
there's more chaos now but there's more
freedom
you know a lot more freedom of choice
no need for me to thank you very much
space oddity i miss the man
yeah i'm not one of those people that
gets all upset about celebrity deaths
like sometimes they'll be like oh man
that's sad or whatever
but we went out to the club the night he
died
or yeah either that or with the next
step where's the next day
because i remember i was i was at work
when i heard about it so they played
bowie all night long
man everybody was crying yep it was
something
yeah because it was like i mean it's
eyebar everyone was 80s night
yeah so everybody there was like a
massive bowie fan
it was like 70s and 80s bowie throughout
the whole [ __ ] night it wasn't
all bowie but it was just lots of bowie
yeah
and everybody knew what was going on
yeah it was like
it was sad but it was also kind of like
cool because everybody
was you can't sit around and get old
forever eventually you got checked out
and he went out like a [ __ ] man
making music videos and singing
yeah he's got videos where he's
referring to his own death and [ __ ]
merging with the consciousness
with the galactic [ __ ] universal
conscious
he he knew what was going on and nobody
else understood it he released those
videos they're like what exactly is
going on
because he didn't tell anybody he had
terminal cancer yeah
it wasn't until the release of the damn
videos or that
that that it made sense why he was
making the videos with coins over his
eyes and stuff
yeah yeah i mean you know it was just
kind of very
he was always very meticulous about
constructing
his image you know what i mean and not
like in a bad way not in the shallow way
or anything like that but he was just
very good at managing
and the [ __ ] took the piss out
of his [ __ ] up to the very last
minute his dying words
to the public were tell them that i was
a closeted heterosexual
not some oscar wilde
you know what you know what oscar wilde
reported last words were right
either those curtains go or i do okay
and he died
i don't know if that's really what he
said or not but that's the legend
david bowie is the leader of the largest
group of supervillains on earth sure
um yeah tila was saying that she really
liked black star
yeah it was good i mean all his [ __ ] is
good
yeah but that's what he was talking
about when he was dancing backwards he
comes out of the closet
in his room to sing the song and then
he's dancing backwards going back into
the closet he was a closeted header
back in the clown going with good back
in the closet just like that just like
that
[ __ ] [ __ ] with you and [ __ ]
it's just like that south park episode
tom cruise needs to come out of closet
yeah that's what i thought
tom cruise and kanye need to come out of
the closet in the south park where is it
he's a gay fish that's pretty the game
that was [ __ ] hilarious man
i haven't watched south park in a
million years is it even still on yeah
it's still on i know the simpsons are
still on absolutely and i'm pretty sure
family guy's still on
i just can't keep up with it man i can't
keep up with everything
you know i got so i got so much [ __ ] i
gotta watch i got new [ __ ] i gotta watch
i got old [ __ ] that i gotta
watch i got [ __ ] man i'm like i said
i got books i gotta read
holy crap i'm never gonna live long
enough to get through all this [ __ ]
i got so many lists victor garcia says
tom cruise is a power bottom yeah he
jumps up and [ __ ] in the air and
comes down on you ass
first you gotta aim to catch him on his
way down
he's pretty small probably you got it
you could put a target you could put a
target around it so you can aim for it
no i'm [ __ ] with you tom he's not
watching this show
tom might be watching me man little
little sawed-off short toms watch each
other we gotta [ __ ] keep each other
every short motherfucker's name tom and
we've got a short sound club
complex you gotta keep an eye on one
it's a complex
it's just like see we know little people
too i know little people like [ __ ]
tito is a friend of mine he's a little
he's
he's a dwarf and he works at universal
you don't understand the egos involved
in little people all right dwarves
cannot tolerate the presence of other
dwarves and
in in their mix because you want to be
the only one yes there can be only one
and he starts [ __ ] saying that kind
of [ __ ] like he's like he's the highest
there can be only one
and he yeah and he's and he's latino so
he does it all with the accent i can't
stand that
[ __ ] look at him look at him
yeah
he had another he had another because he
was younger than him all right he was
younger than him
but i at least i saw that guy maybe one
time yeah
he had the other had the other dwarf out
there dancing with [ __ ] full-size
women
and you know they were cute and and they
were [ __ ] oh look at him look at him
he's dancing
and [ __ ] tito's standing next to me
because look at that [ __ ] i
can't stand him look at him
look at him yeah he was waking up yeah
yeah look at him he was tom
i want you to go take me up and i want
it and throw me off
i want you to throw me off yeah he
wanted he wanted me to dwarf toss it
throw him off the balcony throw him off
the balcony
[Laughter]
yeah man i can do it because he he was
he was involved in the
dwarf tossing and wrestling and [ __ ]
like that so he he's an acrobat
his entertainer and i was like dude you
can get me in trouble she goes yeah get
you in trouble for dwarf tossing ah
that's [ __ ] funny you know yeah he
thinks that shit's hilarious yeah
i love tito he's awesome i haven't seen
him in a while like i said he works at
the uh the cat shelter too
like he works at universal and he's he's
like a minion and stuff but
um yeah he either works or he volunteers
yeah at uh aspca or something like that
like he's he's a
big cat guy yeah so he's always like
trying to adopt cats out
it is a bunch of them up there universal
and at disney and they all know each
other and they're all vying over the
same girls
they're all chasing after the same dwarf
girls
and they they're real judgmental about
who's got the
best figure who's who's most
proportionate
who's who's just like any subculture you
know what i mean
who's the who's got the best face who's
got the best voice
who's the smartest and the egos are
[ __ ] huge
and they really kind of
they talk to us we're the normies
they're mostly doing the [ __ ]
because of the competition between them
and
then they start [ __ ] with each other
about what their jobs are oh that
motherfucker's working at disney
oh he's working at disney and what oh i
work at universe
what's better [ __ ] disney
just said what no i'm just saying
anything that is different they're gonna
get on it
yeah he worked at he worked at disney
like i said it's any in any kind of
subculture
yeah yeah yeah the same thing gods are
[ __ ] too yeah funny
not so much not so much well we're kind
of [ __ ] but not we're we're too old
for that [ __ ] usually
uh tila says i'm surprised none of tom's
ex-wives have written tell all books
well he just has the one that's that one
actually he just has the one x yeah
and i just have the one ex-husband yeah
it's not like we have a long strength
yeah and i wasn't married to her for
very long we didn't have any children or
anything so she's not like
vindictive you know she's living her own
life
living your own life i mean i
i've been with jenny for about 10 years
i was only knew my first wife for like
two years yeah yeah i was only with her
for like two years so
she just was really just a girlfriend if
you look at it in that perspective
and you were fairly young yeah although
i don't think you were as young as i was
when i got married
i um i think i had just turned 30 when i
got married oh see i was 22.
i just got i think i just turned 30.
yeah i was married for 15 years
i was 30 and she was probably about 26
27.
okay well then there you go yeah
david june says tom sounds like tattoo
from fantasy island that's wait
wait he's kind of what tito sounds like
actually he sounds like that's why
i think he's puerto rican yeah i think
he said he was puerto rican yeah
victor says i bought jurassic park the
book but i'm so burned out with school i
don't know if i'm down to do any reading
it's like i yeah i understand that i
really really like
i mean the reason that i wanted to start
doing the book review show is to kind of
force myself to get back into fiction
reading again because
i'm really bummed out that i didn't do
it because not only like i used to read
a lot like i used to read [ __ ]
you know two or three books a week easy
but for a long time for years and years
i kind of got into like nonfiction so i
missed out on like so much horror
fiction and i felt really bad about it
for whatever reason
so like the past year i've just been
like watching all these other booktube
you know booktubers and like being like
give me some recommendations like i have
some books that i'm going to reread and
stuff but
i just wanted i was like what are the
what's the best [ __ ] you guys have read
it's like i'll buy it um so you know i
got the
kindle unlimited thing so i can read
like some ebooks i have this big pile
i'm gonna go through
so i've been i've been really trying to
like [ __ ] at least get one book a
week
tiva said no tom cruise's ex-wife's not
tom
[Laughter]
okay uh they can't because they sign all
kinds of non-disclosure
scientologists will have them killed no
during those divorce agreements and
everything they they have all these
non-disclosure
acts and they did get sued and and
during the times that they were all
married they have [ __ ]
their marriage and divorce agreements
are [ __ ] astounding because it
involves [ __ ] studios
and [ __ ] talent agents and all kinds
of people well wasn't a lot of that like
kind of set up that's what i heard yeah
but they're like brands yeah you can't
break up and talk [ __ ] about it
about each other because it would cause
it might cause other people to lose
money
yeah so no when they break up they can't
say anything about each other
which and unless you're a b list or c
list but if you're a list
if you're an a list celebrity no you
well like i said that kind of goes
you know that goes way back it's like i
think people now are kind of like a
little more open than they were back
then but like back then
you definitely couldn't if you went to
[ __ ] rehab or anything like that man
they were just like [ __ ] hushing that
[ __ ] up
all kind of [ __ ] they had to hush up
murders yeah
but back in those days mgm and those
other studios were [ __ ]
not only were they extremely rich they
were powerful they were very corrupt
and they owned the police they owned
[ __ ] they had
mafia ties if you cost them money that
could cost you your life
especially back in the 20s 20s and 30s
well remember i don't know if we ever
talked about on the show but there was
kind of um i think we did because i
think we did like a
you know hollywood crimes or whatever
like from back in the old days because
you talked about fatty arbuckle and
stuff
i think i talked about william desmond
taylor he was kind of like a silent film
uh dude he was like an actor and
director and he got murdered
like somebody shot him in the back they
don't know who it was i suspect it was
probably a
girlfriend or something but um
basically he got shot in the back he was
laying in the front of his house
and like his housekeeper his ballet or
whatever found him
and the first people they called not the
cops they called the studio heads
and they sent somebody over they didn't
clean up the crime scene
necessarily but they came and like took
out anything from the house that could
be incriminating i mean it was during
prohibition so they took out alcohol
they took out um love letters that he
had from his girlfriends
they do they cleaned all that [ __ ] out
they found it later
but yeah at the time like the cops were
in on all this [ __ ] too yeah they owned
the police
they could get that they could get the
cops to stop an investigation
they could do anything well i mean you
have enough money yeah you can kind of
get
enough money and enough pull and the
police chief [ __ ] likes you because
you're helping him out and sending
actresses his way
they'll do anything they're all on a
tape especially back in the 20s and the
30s
california government u.s government
corrupt
corrupt
you're to on par with mexico yeah we're
still going right
yeah yeah okay because i was just going
to say i don't i don't know
well yeah i'm going to need one in a
minute too but um
well i always kind of worry like if if i
haven't had a chat come up in a while
you don't know what they're talking
okay what's the last thing okay
so you're you're the same as me
sometimes i worry if there's
if there's not a comment for a little
while i'm always kind of like oh
you know what i mean like it's gonna
oracle oracle moms his cut his
that's a that's a girl yeah
okay so it's a girl yeah her comment
hasn't appeared yet
oh okay so it's behind the comments
yeah that's what's worrying me but maybe
you wanted to restart it no because
maybe it'll be okay
like i feel like sometimes it'll do that
and then it'll come back
so i'm just gonna like let it ride my
[ __ ] hasn't frozen up yet
so but you'll have to tell me if anybody
says anything
past that go get another drink but yeah
honestly you know what speaking of the
jurassic park book
i don't think now that i'm thinking
about it i don't think i've read any
michael crichton maybe i read jurassic
park did i
man if i did i don't remember anything
about it i mean i might have read it
because i feel like
like i said there was a time when i was
reading like a whole bunch of books a
week
i used to go to the library every third
weekend
and i would just check out this massive
pile of books
and you know read two or three of them a
week like i said sometimes i'd read a
book in a day
so there you go now see my [ __ ] is
frozen
but it looks like we're still going but
i'm getting kind of worried about it
getting kind of worried about it i'm
looking at his tablet over there
i'm just going to let it ride i'm just
gonna let it ride i'm not gonna touch
anything
and maybe if the internet gods are kind
[Laughter]
it will stop [ __ ] with me
but yeah i'm not a big fan of
uh that kind of
i don't know like i'm not a big fan of
those kind of like you know michael
michael crichton writes a lot of stuff
like uh you know like i kind of
put him in the same thing with like you
know dan brown and people like that
and i never really got into i've read a
couple books like that but i never
really
i don't know i never really liked them
all that much i don't like like
mainstream fiction i guess
maybe i've read a couple like that but i
don't know
i've read a couple dan brown ones too i
think i read the da vinci code and that
other what was the other one that was
like the sequel to da vinci code
there's even like some horror writers
that kind of write like dean cootes
like i've read a couple dean koontz
books but there was something about him
that just
i don't know it just kind of like rubbed
me the wrong way i'm not and i can't put
my finger on what it is
i didn't really i don't like the way
every chapter is written like and at the
end it always has to be a big
cliffhanger
like i kind of felt like i don't
remember which ones of his i read
but i remember like all of the chapters
were kind of like that
and after a while it started to like
kind of piss me off because it seemed
like he was just writing to a formula
kind of thing which is like oh every
chapter has to have this big like
cliffhanger at the end so everybody'll
be like
oh man i got to keep reading you know
what i mean and it seemed like a little
manipulative
i don't know i feel like a lot of kind
of real popular fiction i've read has
been like that and it just i don't know
it gets on my nerves
but i don't know like i said i'm much
more like a horror fiction
person anyway and i like weird
books i like weird [ __ ] the one i'm
reading now
well i don't know i guess that doesn't
matter the one i'm reading now i haven't
finished it yet
this is one that i saw recommended by
somebody like they said this book was
like super scary
this is um it's called sealed by
naomi booth who i think is australian
it's an australian
book that's like pretty good so far it's
kind of like a
it's kind of like a oh [ __ ] i forgot
well that was dumb
but uh the one i read before and i think
that um
the review for that is probably gonna
come go up on monday i read one called
pen pal by dathan auerbach
and that originally started as like
uh reddit posts like on nosleep
and then he turned it into a novel later
on and
i loved that i thought that was [ __ ]
great
but um it's weird because i went on
goodreads after and then it seemed like
the
the the reviews were like super divisive
like you know there were some people
like me that were like oh my god this is
awesome this is one of the best books
ever and it was so creepy and stuff
and then there were some like one star
being like this sucked too hard it was
so badly written blah blah and i was
just like i didn't get it but i was like
i don't know but i loved it
yeah coma's coming up a lot we need to
see that one again
yeah i feel like isn't uh what's her
face like uh genevieve uh
bujold in that who was in dead ringers i
feel like she was in that
did they make a [ __ ] movie out of
every single michael crichton book that
he ever wrote probably
i kind of feel like they did how many
books of that mother he's up there with
stephen king like i was just
writing [ __ ] books all day long
he's writing books in his [ __ ] sleep
yeah i don't understand how they do it
well now i do understand
how they do it it's just you have to get
up what stephen king does
you know and i know the most about him
because i've read all his like bio and
bios and stuff is that he has a rule
that
it doesn't matter if it's a weekend it
doesn't matter if it's a holiday or
whatever he has to write at least 10
pages
at least every day um
so if you do that then you're gonna have
like big [ __ ] doorstop novels
before you even realize it they're in
there talking about tom cruise's height
okay it's very difficult to find
accurate information on any celebrity's
height that they all lie
okay come on in pooh i feel like the
door open what's this doing close
why is this closed that's not a lot of
time about time
like i have a feeling
based on looking at boots and looking at
sylvester stallone when he's standing at
other people
i have a feeling that actually still
semester stallone is 5'7
yeah they just do but i think they give
him like five
ten and i don't think so i'm more like
five seven i think
and i've heard that he's not as big as
people thought he was when he when they
met him but then you look at
tom cruise tom cruise is wearing special
shoes and all that kind of [ __ ] and they
shoot him in a certain way to make him
look but
i kind of think tom cruise is somewhere
between five four and five six
maybe he's five five which makes him
only maybe like a couple inches shorter
than
sylvester stallone so it's not that big
of a difference between the two
but for some reason tom cruise is
getting [ __ ] pigeon holed as being
the
sawed-off [ __ ] there's a lot of
sawed-off [ __ ] in the hollywood
just not noticing them
and i don't know why they're [ __ ]
doing that specifically to tom maybe
just because
he does [ __ ] he's done crazy [ __ ]
so they have to find a way to [ __ ] with
him
what are you doing the hell is she doing
back there trying to open boxes
what's in here some some a lot of what
they do and say about tom cruise has
become kind of like a he's become a meme
and
he's been he's kind of fun to [ __ ] with
because he does crazy [ __ ] he's
diabolical he's very he's a he every
people know i'm saying
[ __ ] diabolical all right
poke knock it the [ __ ] off
thank you do you hear that she's gonna
go okay then she's gonna start gonna
wear off
as soon as you turn around so i where
where was i
okay cruising getting distracted they're
trying to come
they try to come up with ways to [ __ ]
with tom cruise and get underneath the
skin
um he's not a typical hollywood person
which that's kind of a good thing
because a typical hollywood dude is a
[ __ ] douchebag
so i i'm not gonna say he's cool i think
he's a douche bag too
it's just that i think he tends towards
because of scientology
he tends towards anti-communist and
probably kind of right-wing
but not conservative not in like a 1980s
version of conservative he's a cultist
which kind of puts him in a more bizarre
category
he thinks he's an elite jedi from a
[ __ ] commando unit
made by ron hubbard to [ __ ] stop
[ __ ] an alien
alien possession and get these [ __ ]
alien souls
off of your soul well gosh it's a good
thing that we have people like him here
he can stop time he can slow time down
you can stop time go
back in time and and reverse a problem
in the whole track and then go and then
proceed
therefore nothing bad can happen to you
because you actually projected
backwards in time there's all kinds of
[ __ ] supposedly he knows how to do
based upon his ot level
it's a fascinating [ __ ] it's a
fascinating mindset
do i think there's anything to it no no
of course not
he thinks there's something to it though
i think i think he does
i think you know what i think it would
be really funny it's like if i ever
met him and he started that [ __ ]
with me or something like that and he's
just like
i can do this that the other thing
because you know that's what he would do
we would just like keep talking
and then i would just like leave a gap
and then i'd be like big deal i can do
that
he's got a weird genesis i mean
he's coming out of a alistarian crolite
style make a [ __ ] a wizard
religion by written up by a sci-fi
writer a charismatic sci-fi writer who
could [ __ ]
funny [ __ ] mouth but but he was by
all accounts [ __ ] very
popular among among the cult
and he was successful i mean he built a
[ __ ] religion i i
i haven't built a religion and has all
kinds of [ __ ] buildings and secret
bases and
they're in there larping with [ __ ]
psychic powers and
ufos and extraterrestrial demons and
it's [ __ ] it's a trip and then it's
got a paramilitary
aspect to it where they're training and
training for mental power like a jedi
mental powers weapons some of them you
know
i imagine tom cruise tom cruise can't
shoot i have seen him
he can shoot he was you know he could
ride motorcycles
he's got a lot of motorcycles cold ones
he is
he can fly an aircraft i think he can
fly helicopters and airplanes
um he owns them from what i understand
well he's got enough money so he's got a
lot of money
so in a lot of ways he's not really uh
your average actor who's like a joke
who's pretending that he can do all this
[ __ ] he can really can
so i respect him for that um but
um i think that the fact that he can do
a lot of that stuff
is made him just completely he's
arrogant yeah
he's very arrogant but so is david
miscavige the guy who runs
scientology i mean because look keanu
reeves can do a lot of that [ __ ]
too and he's cool so you don't have to
be
like a total [ __ ] tape i just think
that he's that way
because he came from a world of
make-believe around a bunch of fake
people so he assumes everybody's fake
you know in a certain way yeah i mean
yeah
no i don't think he projects that upon
like saying military personnel who
really can't fly f
f-14s he pretended to fly
he tended to fly an f-14 and tom in top
gun
but there are guys that really did fly
f-14 so he's not going to
really talk [ __ ] about f-14s to them
it's just it's just a very weird
situation i would like to meet
tom cruise and come to my own conclusion
not me
why not because i think he'd be annoying
as [ __ ] well that's if that's the case
then you know what i mean let the chips
fall where they may
i would like to meet tom cruise just and
have a drink with tom cruise
and and see for myself what it is you're
dealing with
um i'm pretty sure a lot of it's
exaggerated
but i'm not gonna say he's ultra cool
he's probably a [ __ ] real
um difficult to deal with because
scientology would make you difficult to
deal with
yeah it does it will even just like the
people that are down in the [ __ ]
trenches yeah that are irritating as
[ __ ]
yeah you know well they're they're kind
of know-it-alls
yeah and i can't oh that kind of person
just pissing me off so much and like so
i kind of feel like because even when i
worked with the [ __ ]
and these people were not rich and
famous like tom cruise
these were just like regular ass
[ __ ] and a regular ass [ __ ]
job
and they were insufferable enough so i
can imagine
how bad he is the power and money and
everything like that that he has
would make you like a hundred times
worse yeah
and more in suffering i could deal with
something so no thanks
i could deal with tom cruise
[Laughter]
because we're about the same size and
the first thing to do well probably you
could but like you man i don't have any
patience for that kind of crap i just
don't
well the first thing i would let him
know is that [ __ ] um
i'm a man that's like some [ __ ] that
that's like you should say some sideways
[ __ ] to me
[Laughter]
okay that's in my history that's what i
did for a living i will [ __ ] you up
okay and uh no you cross me you're gonna
get hurt
so i'd let him know that real fast i
don't give a [ __ ] about his lawyers i'm
not scared of doing time i will [ __ ] you
up
i'll say yeah what are you in here for i
[ __ ] up tom cruise all right yeah man
i got six my [ __ ] knocking teeth out
stop time all right so
i don't give a [ __ ] you're dealing with
a kamikaze you could probably get it
on my jacket i come from comic con style
units
just look up [ __ ] tiger force man
[ __ ] 506.
but now i approach you
i give respect i expect to get respect
we're going to talk that way
if it goes sideways i punish you i just
do
i i think i believe if you're a man if
you're a woman i'll let it slide
but if you're a man i punish you i think
it'd be funny if he tried to pull some
[ __ ] and then
yeah and then you did something and then
you tried to do like some wizard [ __ ]
i'd be ready for
that [ __ ] he's going to like you're
going to throw chee balls or something
like that yeah he's going to throw a
cheetah
that's a different thing that sweet spot
and you wouldn't even know what happened
you wake up a couple minutes later what
was that
what's this brown slick stain
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] you up okay you're gross i'll
get that [ __ ] on video
what i did you yeah no i ain't gonna
talk [ __ ] but i'm just saying that you
just did though
of course the humor i don't think he's
[ __ ] really get out of line
um if you if you show weakness he'd get
out of his line but i don't show
weakness
looking look at who i assert whoever so
you've seen me associate with some big
scary [ __ ] we're friends
yeah that is because i give respect and
i get respect back and [ __ ] you know
i listen to your stories and you listen
to my stories and i prove my story you
prove your stories and
that we're all [ __ ] france you know
what i mean and
if you [ __ ] get sideways
it's gonna be bad
[Laughter]
but no i don't think he'd do that i
don't think he'd do that
i think he'd probably make me mad by
accident just by his [ __ ]
demeanor because i've seen his demeanor
and i could see how a guy like that
might go a little bit sideways
yeah i mean his demeanor pisses me off
just seeing him
maybe so in person he's probably like
way worse i kind of think he would make
assumptions that
the erroneous assumptions about me
yeah he probably would well like i said
that's something that i don't because
one thing and this even came across um
in the 80s when he was in acting roles
he comes across as a very arrogant i
know everything [ __ ]
you know what i mean if that's a
legitimate if that's who he really is
because he's an actor
he might be yeah but every movie that
he's in
he kind of plays that same kind of thing
so i kind of feel like that's probably
just what he's like
you know what i mean maybe i kind of
think what it is is that
scientology and being an actor he's
exuding strong
energy of a [ __ ] of an alpha
male that is very competent he's
basically what's his name ethan
yeah which i love the mission impossible
movies i think he's i think he's great
in them
i think he's a very good performer
is he a great actor actors have [ __ ]
range
dustin hoffman was a great actor okay he
could convince me of some [ __ ]
but after a while he ends up being
dustin hoffman in every [ __ ] movie
but some of his but he did really good
[ __ ] in some of his movies look
like his working rain man is tom cruise
a great actor no but he's a great
performer
yeah and i think yeah i think we've
talked about that before it's like right
honestly my criteria for a great actor
is can you make me forget that you are
acting and
can i forget who you are even if you're
famous i have never for one single
moment forgotten that that was tom
cruise no it's always tom cruise it's
tom cruise playing himself
or playing playing alpha alpha version
of himself
just because it's on screen it's an
illusion you know what i mean so i'm not
going to judge him based upon his
on-screen illusion his on-screen
persona he's he's performing like in
that
mummy movie that thing [ __ ] bombed i
actually liked that movie
i did not i liked it i thought it was a
good
old-school style blockbuster okay
it came out late that should have been
something from like five years earlier
it they should have just kept rolling
with it and leaning into it and making
more of them it was kind of like
underworld
it should actually i didn't like
underworld either underwood made a lot
of money
i know it did but i didn't like it
should have been that should have been
going around the same time as underworld
that's what it reminded me of which is
probably why i didn't really care for it
i don't like that i'm not a big fan of
that horror action crossover kind of
thing it can be done well
like i liked blade i like that kind of
stuff but a lot of the movies that kind
of came out around that time
that were like we're gonna it's like a
horror movie but it's like a big action
kind of there's kung fu
and [ __ ] i i don't know man i don't like
that
like i said i if if i want to watch a
horror movie i want to watch some like
disturbing scary [ __ ] i don't want to
see like kung fu and all that kind of
crap
that's like dude put that in an action
movie i don't like really i don't like
those hybrids
no with some exceptions there are some
exceptions obviously but in general
which is which is why
i knew that i wasn't gonna like the
mommy because i saw the trailer
and i was kind of like oh i'm suspecting
that it's gonna go like in an underworld
direction and i didn't like underworld
and so when i saw it i was like yep that
was pretty much
exactly what i was expecting uh that was
exactly what i was afraid of
and i don't care for it rick said that
last mission impossible
he was badass not gonna lie though yeah
it was i think it was i actually
i liked it yeah i liked it too we saw in
the theater yeah it was every bit as
good as the newer james bond movies
which man that the james bond movie that
they're making right now man they
[ __ ] re-shot
so much of that [ __ ] over and over again
i just that's not
that motherfucker's gonna bomb that's
and when mg
mgm is selling that's part of it
is because they spent so much [ __ ]
money on that movie
you just lost your uh no it went away a
long time ago
i'm just kind of hoping that it'll come
up hopefully the stream won't crash
people if it does we'll be back
go ahead and take a break we'll be back
a couple minutes later we'll [ __ ]
reboot but i'm just like i said i'm some
because sometimes if you just let it
ride because sometimes like my [ __ ]
keeps freezing up like the screen that
i'm looking at
but if you just kind of like keep
talking and keep going sometimes
it will uh come back on its own so i'm
kind of hoping because i have a thing
that's supposed to
just reconnect like automatically yeah
so a lot of times the only time that i
actually have to restart is if the whole
[ __ ] just freezes
and i can't even move the mouse or
anything yeah victor says amazon's
buying mgm yeah they're buying mgm
and they're gonna amazon's gonna lose
its ass i would never buy mgm
amazon has so much money they probably
don't give a [ __ ] they better
i mean you know because that catalog is
not going to make much money i don't
think
well like i said i mean amazon prime is
kind of like their big massive thing and
i kind of like
i like amazon prime because they they
offer pretty much anything you want to
watch
yeah i mean is on there even if you got
to pay a couple bucks to rent it
so it's like i'm not really worried
about anything that's going to like
expand the catalog
i think is going to be for over a year
over a year
hollywood amc you know hollywood in the
theaters
chains did not want to admit what was
coming and what was coming is the
digital
digitization and live streaming of all
the movies and the death of
of movie theaters or at least the death
of
large movie theater chains like
multiplex yeah i think they'll be
theaters um and they'll live but they'll
just live stream like you do at home and
you're eating dinner while you're
watching and then you know
like i said if you have something like
that like alamo drafthouse or
like uh the enzian theater in orlando
where you it's like a cafe
you can get wine you can get food and
they'll do like themed nights like we're
gonna do all these cult movies like all
night you know
we'll do david lynch all one night or
something like that it's like people
like to go to that because it's like an
event you know
yeah i think things like that will
survive yeah but it has to be like a
specialty thing but that's kind of the
way everything's going everything's
going there's nothing wrong with that
so i mean the whole idea that you can
live stream a brand new movie from home
that was something that rich people have
had for 15 years it's just
you didn't know about it didn't that's
something they've been doing that
forever
and they just did it under different
guys as like they would have
an amc theater on their private compound
with a [ __ ] it look like you're
walking in a damn theater it might
it might only had one theater or maybe
two
but it had the popcorn and all that [ __ ]
and they'd bring
they'd have movie night and go by
themselves or with their girlfriends or
their girlfriend's girlfriend's
girlfriends and their [ __ ] entourage
and go and watch a movie in the live
stream digitally on a screen
they've been doing that for [ __ ] 10
years that was only the very ultra rich
you know and it's it would say amc it
would be an amc decor
they would pay for it all though that's
all obsolete now
now you can do it through your smart tv
well yeah
so it's funny and i mean you got people
bitching about modern life
you can go down to the hood and
[ __ ] got ac
and in his pocket he has a [ __ ]
device
that a [ __ ] imperial lord from
[ __ ] two or three hundred years ago
could have never had
dreamed of having access to that much
power and information just in his
[ __ ] pocket
and the idea that you have don't have
dirt floors and you have [ __ ] central
air or just
even a window unit you know and that you
can get fresh food that wasn't rotten
and didn't have [ __ ] bugs in it
these are things that only very very
[ __ ] rich people had
even up to just like 100 years ago well
yeah well
like i said even in our lifetimes
remember if you missed a movie at the
theater
that was it i mean you missed it it's
like you either had to wait until it
came out on cable like a year or two
later maybe or came out on tv
or if you wanted to rent it like
sometimes i mean when we were kids
you didn't really you know you know you
could rent it later on
if you wanted to buy it it was like a
hundred dollars for one [ __ ] vhst
yeah people take all this [ __ ] for
granted we are now experiencing the
[ __ ] highest point in human
civilization even though some shit's
falling apart
it's falling apart because it's [ __ ]
obsolete i've been studying this [ __ ]
i don't do just this show i sit around
and listen to [ __ ] some of the
greatest [ __ ]
independent thinkers and professors the
world has ever known how
[ __ ] youtube of all [ __ ] things
you can forget any information and
listen to any wise man from across the
[ __ ] world
you're a wise woman
[Laughter]
we are living in times of unprecedented
resources and [ __ ] freedom and mental
freedom
free your [ __ ] mind stop [ __ ]
judging things
based on what other person tells you
look at it in historical context
we are all even the poorest of us are is
extremely rich
compared to even just 50 years ago
well yeah even 50 years ago yeah i
already know that
[Laughter]
there was [ __ ] uh what was that i
think it was howard hughes or one of the
damn
uh one of the jp morgan's one of the
more spent
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
dollars to make an air conditioner just
to air condition
one room to keep it at about 68 degrees
and the air conditioner was the size of
a [ __ ] room well yeah built on top of
a thing
even though just a [ __ ] 200 window
unit could do what what that thing could
do and he spent hundreds of thousands of
dollars on
on an air conditioner well yeah remember
how like big computers used to be
computer you still take up a whole
[ __ ]
you'd have a whole big [ __ ] facility
to put that [ __ ] in yeah
[ __ ] that you can do on your [ __ ]
phone now yeah you know what i mean
and uh youtube when television appeared
it actually
started to cut into the uh profits of
hollywood in theaters
but it was considered trash yeah really
trash television television now is
better than anything that would have
ever been in the movies in the 80s
with these new series you know well yeah
like i said it's almost kind of like a
second golden age yes i feel like there
was a lot of good [ __ ] on like
the 80s that's up too but maybe the
writing wasn't that good but the but the
way the quality of the filming and the
[ __ ] the music and the
special effects oh man better in star
wars in the 70s i mean do you know
what was like a precursor of that was uh
twin peaks
in the 90s because that was kind of the
first first big
budget well that yeah that was like kind
of one of the first like tv shows
that was structured and thought of
like a film like one big long film and
it was kind of like really revolutionary
for the time so look what that [ __ ]
did
you know what i mean zachary says i'm so
glad i don't live in an era
i said he fought he spent five dollars
super chat i'm so glad i don't live in
an
era of cropped and pan scanned vhs
versions off it
and more what is that what am i looking
at
anamorphic anamorphic movies yeah i mean
it's just it's funny for us
because we saw a lot of these kind of
old movies like horror movies and sci-fi
and stuff
and we saw them a lot growing up and you
saw them either on tv or you saw them on
vhs
and they kind of look like crap and it's
kind of like you still enjoyed them
but they the quality was kind of shitty
so for a long time you just thought it
was like this cheap throwaway kind of
movie
and then now that it's been restored and
you see it on blu-ray you're like
wow that's actually um gorgeous
yeah that looks really nice it's like
that was made by competent people where
you thought somebody just like filmed it
with a [ __ ]
you know victor said two things he said
i sold my amc stock just today
and then later on he goes youtube is not
research yes and no depends on where
you're looking
i gotta go to the bathroom you can
actually go on youtube
and [ __ ] listen to ted talks you can
you can you can directly access nasa
you can directly access um [ __ ]
dissertations from scholars from all
around the world
you can go in there and watch live
streams of what's happening inside the
senate or the congress
it's unparalleled to anything in in
history
you can see you can uh you can access
the works of [ __ ] great authors on
audiobooks through youtube
youtube has [ __ ] problems i mean it's
not going to be
the the the platform of the future
there's going to be better ones coming
uh things that are uncensored
uh things that you pay for that are like
encrypted
or real secure blockchain type [ __ ]
where
a third party can't come in and stop it
or block it um
as time goes on you're gonna have freer
and freer access to [ __ ] information
that you would have paid
thousands and thousands of dollars for
by going to some university
uh but no instructional stuff um quick
tutorials on how to assemble
and disassemble [ __ ] a dryer or a
washing machine
how engines work uh
[ __ ] how to assemble and disassemble
firearms throughout the [ __ ] ages
history of firearms history of
individual units
military units and all the wars it's all
there
even the uh interviews with guys that
fought in certain battles
it's youtube you could laugh at youtube
but there's so much [ __ ] great
information there if you know what to
look for well yeah it's just i mean it's
just a platform it's just a platform i
mean there's good [ __ ] on there there's
a bunch of terrible [ __ ] on there it's
like as long as you know what you're
looking for
you can find the works of friedrich
nietzsche an audiobook for free right
there
and sit there and listen to all his
[ __ ] and same thing with arthur
scopenhauer
all right anything or schopenhauer
people getting mad it's not
scoping howard schopenhauer whatever
okay i'm white i'm going to [ __ ]
america from the south i'm almost
scoping however
i saw it pronounced in one of the in an
old in an old
dictionary that i had because i looked
it up with a k in the pronunciation
so it might be just regional i don't
know i mean i always thought it was
scopenhauer
because i thought i in most languages i
mean um
you know ch sounding like that's not
really a thing i think it's a thing in
italian but only if it's followed by an
eye okay if anybody i only studied
italian for like a year so i don't
really remember
but i thought normally it's pronounced
like a hard that with a k
c sound i think but you know actually i
remember seeing it written in the
pronunciation
the only languages i've studied are
french spanish
and italian a little bit and welsh um
you know and which and in welsh ch is
always
like a hard sound i think yeah i'm
trying to remember
but uh yeah yeah so oh see my [ __ ]
caught up yeah i did
catch you sorta saw that i knew if i
waited long enough
yeah i just you're about you're about
eight
you're you're about yeah but it was
better what happened is i have
my obs window open and then i have the
youtube chat window open
and what ended up happening was the
youtube chat window it stopped and then
it went
black like everything went black it just
went away but my but it was still going
and then it kind of came back but it was
blank there was nothing there and then
it kind of went black again and then it
just now came back
yeah i got a lot of people in there
backing me up there uh
saying all the great poetry and authors
and
and everything are and yeah philosophers
they're there on youtube
well and i listen to like old victorian
ghost stories and [ __ ] like that i love
to watch eyeless
it's a good platform for certain things
uh if you want very spicy
language and just funny [ __ ] if you want
to go back in time the way youtube was
in the [ __ ]
90s or early 2000s it's bit shoot
bit shoot you're gonna have crazy
[ __ ] uh
just of all stripes on there because
they're they're not being censored
and that was the internet i broke i grew
up with you know came up with
was you never knew what was going to be
on there somebody dressing up in damn
women's clothing with a damn
bunny rabbit hair hairdo beating off and
[ __ ] hitting himself in the head with
a damn bottle it just
it was crazy [ __ ] that used to be on the
internet crazy
well that's still on there it would be
on there but it would take a long time
to take it off or they
sometimes they'd never take it off you
know or just creepy videos or somebody
just talking about crazy [ __ ]
there was one youtube channel that i
used to check i subscribed to
but then i had to silence it it was a
russian woman
who would post probably about six times
a day who had uh
schizophrenia who would talk into her
phone
russian gibberish and dance around and
then point at things as if
and then would would talk about putin
i could hear her saying sounds riveting
couldn't understand
it it was just [ __ ] hilarious you
know i mean someone re
after a while like she's posted too many
times and the comments
on it were [ __ ] hilarious the
comments were hilarious
because she'd just be pointing at her
pillow and yelling at it and [ __ ]
saying russian gibberish
and she could tell that she was
schizophrenic you know see to me that
kind of stuff
is maybe funny for like 30 seconds and
i'm like okay that's
that's getting old well yeah eventually
i
event then that channel disappeared that
that became
marginal content well i don't really
want to laugh at somebody with mental
health issues you know
i was laughing at the comments really
because the comments the comments
there's a lot there's a running
discussions of you know
because she would also um
like record her social worker who was a
young guy
who would come who would check come and
check on her and help her out make sure
she was taking care of it it's kind of
like that weird channel with like that
korean woman that was kind of like stuck
in her apartment and she thought people
were kind of she'd sleeps all the time
or that weird ass child it's real famous
i think we even when we did that show
about like weird youtube channels i
think we talked on there but i can't
remember what her name is
i think she's korean i didn't see that
one but she has schizophrenia too i
think yeah
and it's the same kind of thing she
sleeps most of the time she films
herself 24 7 pretty much
okay yeah and uh she also has
schizophrenia and she thinks that
people are coming and like doing stuff
and like moving stuff around in her
apartment
to keep track of it make sure yeah it's
kind of sad but it's like kind of creepy
but i guess like they have somebody
she's kind of famous so i guess people
kind of come by and like
make sure she's not doing anything bad
like she's not hurting herself or
whatever but
she has somebody that's like looking
after her but it's like pretty weird
um but yeah i don't know i kind of feel
like
i mean i do a lot of um you know i watch
a lot of documentaries on youtube about
usually about whatever uh you know topic
we're gonna do for the show
because i like to read a bunch of [ __ ]
about it and i like to
have some documentaries about it going
on in the background so i can kind of
get
you know so i try to do that but
mostly i mean my youtube suggested feed
is either all
uh cute cat stuff or horror movie stuff
or murder stuff is pretty much all of it
and scary stories like i really like
because sometimes if i'm working on
something like graphic design or
whatever
then i usually like to just have if you
go to like mr nightmare
or like channels like that where they
just have like a six hour video
of just somebody with a cool voice like
reading like creepy ass true stories
that people have sent in like from
reddit or whatever i subscribe to a
british dude named mark feldman
and he's a historian a military
historian
and he'll make video specials with
photos about
just weird stuff from that happened in
wars it could be any war
world war ii world war one vietnam
even the the newer wars and it's just
like
strange aspects like what happened to
hitler's car
you know what i mean weird [ __ ] like
that what happened to
to um um what was his name horman
goring's boat
he had a private yacht and and it it
still exists somebody owns it in the
history of that yacht
um lost nazi gold uh rumors of the nazi
super weapons like the bell he talks
about that you know
there's one he put out a couple weeks
ago about the 63rd vaffin ss
div ss division which were all recruited
from prison
weird huh they were all recruited from
prison and the leader was
a [ __ ] known child rapist
he was ex-military but they put him in
charge of this thing
and they did [ __ ] crimes that were so
heinous
they were an internal security unit
that they actually that the the normal
ss
commanders [ __ ] thought thought that
they had to be deactivated that they
were like
embarrassed of the [ __ ] that they were
doing and they
were doing things like they went into
poland and [ __ ] annihilated and
entitled
an entire um uh orphanage filled with
children
and they did it with bayonets that's
pretty [ __ ] up they were ordered to do
it
it's all pretty [ __ ] weird though huh
i mean that's like wow
they said don't waste ammo just go in
there with [ __ ] bayonets and they
bayoneted all these kids in the
orphanages
for some reason uh that was like
it was just like one of the things they
were just trying to clear out it would
clear out people it was a war of
annihilation there was we have to
annihilate these people
because we don't like them you know and
we're not going to pay for their orphans
so kill all their orphans and imagine
the dudes that what kind of dude it
takes to do that
a psychopath yeah they were saying they
were sexual psychopaths too they were
raping everybody
they were raping people and then killing
them
and it kind of and it kind of like
explained some of the stuff i had heard
about what had happened on the eastern
front
and it was probably the 63rd that was
doing that
the ss divisions were like these
[ __ ] are unacceptable and
that's bad when the ss divisions they're
saying
these [ __ ] aren't yeah you're
pretty [ __ ] up when you've been the
nazis yeah it's
pretty like yeah that's going a little
farther you gotta go dial that back
yeah yeah yeah yeah you guys need to
look that one up man the 63rd vacant ss
there's a whole history of them and it
was kind of classified but
the information's out there now and they
got
in the end the germans fed them to the
damn war machine fighting the russians
only like 20 or 30 of them survived yeah
yeah so they had no intention of those
dudes ever surviving the war
that's a weird thing when you think
about it let's get these guys out of
prison to kill our enemies and then
we'll just throw them to the russians
well yeah and have the russians kill
them but then you don't got to deal with
them yeah
yeah i can see where they're thinking
that's why exactly what they were
thinking fourth drawdown says i found an
audiobook of jenny's latest
recommendation the lost apothecary that
was a pretty good book i didn't love it
uh but it was it was pretty good it
wasn't really a horror novel it was more
like a historical fiction
the mystery thing but i'm always down
for [ __ ] about poisoners
so you know i love that kind of [ __ ]
oracle says recently i've gotten fond of
channels focusing on the history of
clothing
see i like real specific there's this
one dude i can't remember what his
[ __ ] name is but he's a british guy
and he watches historical movies
he's like a historian he watches
historical movies and talks about how
accurate they are
and those are really good and he goes
like super in depth it's like really
good
i was watching this one on amadeus i
watched all this other stuff and i also
like
um dominic noble because he does
he does various other things but kind of
his main thing is called um
lost in adaptation and he talks about
the movie versions of books and he
compares
like how how good the adaptation was uh
from the book like how accurate and what
they changed and [ __ ] like that
and i'm just like really interested in
that kind of stuff so i have a lot of
kind of
[ __ ] like that i like history of food
anything like that
obviously you know what i mean like i
said cat stuff like cat behavior
people training their cats to use those
buttons that have words and [ __ ] because
i was i told
tom i was like man we need to like teach
pookie to talk
i don't think she needs to talk though
because we pretty much know what she's
saying i can tell i can
i know what she wants just by her facial
looks by her facial expression and her
body language
and what she's pointing at she points at
things by going over there and standing
and then she kind of points with her
nose yes
yeah well yeah if she wants to if she
wants something she'll come get you
yeah and then go to it and she'll be
like kind of at your leg going
and then push push it put her face at it
like that like come on
it's usually a bow yeah or a plate she
wants you to put the food there and
there's food already there
it's not enough it's not enough she's
like i know i'm gonna need more than
that yeah yeah
that's the only cat i've ever seen that
plans ahead she's very smart
yeah she's like that's not enough food
yeah because we leave a little plate of
food for her like overnight
yeah she does that late at night when
i'm before we go to sleep because she
knows
that she won't be get a resupply yeah
because we're not going to get up we're
going to get up so she wants to make
sure there's enough there to last her
until we wake up
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] smart i
didn't i had always heard that animals
did not plan ahead that's [ __ ] or
you know he totally does
yeah yeah she does she knows what later
means
yeah and honestly if you talk to her
about like you know you can't go outside
right now you can go outside later
she understands that yeah you know what
i mean she understands like uh you know
words she knows what her name is
all that kind of [ __ ] yeah if you call
her name she turned around look yeah
she's like what what are you talking
about
my drink is empty okay
same thing yeah well that's okay that's
all we got right
i got orange um i don't know the
lemonade was good
yeah hugo said i think old people like
me appreciate the miracle of having any
info at the palm of your hand i remember
you know when i was growing up you know
you didn't have the internet if you
couldn't remember
something like we were kind of like oh
what was that tv show or was that
actor's name or blah blah blah
you had to call the [ __ ] library man
you couldn't go on the [ __ ] internet
either that
or you would just have to like hope you
remembered it because there was no way
like you couldn't it's just funny to
think about it now and it's even funny
for me to think about because you don't
even
it's so ingrained in our lives now that
you can just like [ __ ] know anything
you need to know instantly
but back then it was like a huge pain in
the ass holy crap
i mean i kind of feel like people don't
remember stuff as well anymore i don't
know i don't know if that's the case
though
i still remember [ __ ] but just knowing
that you have that fallback where it's
just kind of like ah if i forget stuff i
can just like look it up on google
although the funny thing is like tom
will usually something that tom does a
lot is he'll be like
we'll be watching a movie or whatever
and he'll be like seeing that he's like
was an actor in that movie when did that
movie come out i'm like
[ __ ] i'm not google it's like you have
a tablet right there look that [ __ ] up i
don't know
oh my god camp guy says uh that he
watches uh he runs youtube at night
while i sleep
yeah i like to have those i really
really like i don't think it's mr
nightmare but there's another
channel that he does like
creepy quote unquote true stories like
no sleep type stuff from reddit
and he will just it'll be like six or
eight hours long and then they'll be
like
relaxing like rain and thunder and stuff
like in the background
we may be losing the connection i like
those uh oh
i don't know if you've lost audio though
you might have audio
oh it came back it came back yikes this
is pissing me off man
just stop it be good internet be good
you guys we didn't lose audio did we
guys
it's it seems to be going yeah probably
not i don't think you know
as i said it was a little t said it was
a little hiccup but we're back yeah
that's what i thought that's what it
looked like
yeah i like a lot of true crime channels
i like um unresolved
i like um bailey saryan she's cute as
[ __ ]
she puts on makeup and talks about your
crime cases
it's super funny uh brain scratch is
good
that guy was on the elisa lamb
documentary actually um
lord and arts i think is the name of the
channel but yeah i like that guy
um [ __ ] man i think i was listening to
because our show
on friday night is going to be about the
west mesa bone collector
which is that serial killer that has not
been
caught in new mexico
and there was unresolved he did like a
three-part uh really in-depth like
documentary about that so i was it was
like three or four hours long so i
listen to that
and then i'm listening to the time suck
as well but i haven't got all the way
through that yet
but yeah i've been reading [ __ ] about
that are we still on yeah you're good i
don't know why your shit's freezing up
because it always does i'm just kind of
like i'm not even looking at it anymore
because [ __ ] it
um oh and i just started and once i
started doing my book review channel i
also started like watching a bunch of
other
book review book reviewers jordaline is
my favorite
jordaline reads she's cute as hell she
does um she mostly does horror she does
thrillers she does some manga
as well um shades of orange is also good
but there's like a bunch of good ones
you know um i don't know
that's where i get a lot of my
recommendations from because otherwise i
wouldn't know what to [ __ ] look for
and her usually her recommendations are
really good
some people are talking about briefcase
i don't think i've maybe seen that
unless i watched some of their stuff and
like didn't realize that that's what the
channel was called
because sometimes i'll just do a search
a random search for
you know whatever the topic is and then
i'll just
watch it without really paying attention
what are you doing i'm trying to move
this thing away from [ __ ]
me it's always in front of me well it's
gotta be somewhere
where can you guys still hear us okay
where we can both
hear like you know it's always like
right now we both have to yell
yeah what i'm gonna get is i'm gonna get
a [ __ ] one
and we'll put the uh a boom yeah
which i'm gonna get all right all right
t sent us a [ __ ] super chat fifteen
dollars thank you g
thank you top five sexiest men or women
in horror movies
this is virginia and tom this is hard
and the chat can bring it
oh my god and i'm gonna have to well in
horror movies crampton probably number
one barbara
barbara crabs would be number one from
uh
from from beyond from beyond well i mean
she was in re-animator she's in a bunch
of stuff but i think because she had
like that outfit on yeah
the next one would be uh girl from um
revenge of the living dead or what was
that return living dead that was what's
her name she's in a bunch of
quigley yeah linnea quickly renea
quigley
probably number two she's cool as hell
too i met her at a horror convention
many years ago and she seemed really
awesome
uh
man this is hard okay it's kind of hard
for me to think of anybody
those are those are good picks though
[Laughter]
i was i was real into like uh jeremy
irons and dead ringers i know that's
weird
i don't remember that way oh that yeah
yeah that guy he played the twin
gynecologist
so i like that um
like you said the chick from the howling
i don't know there's so many yeah she
was only in one movie from there i
remember
that's true it's got to be somebody
who's like regular and horrible like you
could probably lose
movies okay jeffrey combs
yeah i'm gonna say jeffrey combs that's
actually it that's a pretty good uh
observation jeffrey combs
there's some really good look we gotta
have look
i saw some jeffrey combs interviews here
on youtube
with some horror fans and that
[ __ ] is awesome around
fans and he loves youtube
and he gets loaded talking online he
seems like an awesome dude
i'd love to have him on the show
sometimes we should totally get him
all right he call us jeffrey and he's
kind in character he's uh he's just
he puts on the serious actor uh
kind of vibe even though you can tell
he's having a [ __ ] really good time
he takes a lot of breaks to take a leak
because you can see the edits
uh he he he's a dude that enjoys youtube
he would make a very he's a very good
youtube guest
he was super impressed with his host who
had
the resonator from from beyond he had
right yeah we watched that one night
he couldn't jeffrey combs has no idea
how much of an icon he is he doesn't
like maybe he does but it doesn't really
does registers maybe i mean that seems
like a weird
that's got to be so weird he pretends
that he pretends that he's not a horror
legend
because you have that one you have the
the resume somebody
captures that holy crap i would like to
see the resonator i have not seen the
resonator saying
he just he cannot believe that people
remember
all this work evidently that he's done i
told you man horror movie fans will if
you are in like an awesome iconic horror
movie
people will remember you for ever well
not only did you do herbert west he also
did some really good [ __ ] and [ __ ] in
as a gem hadar [ __ ] i forgot what
they were called like a commander in
deep space nine
but my favorite role is
well agent danvers was cool from from um
the frighteners from the frighteners but
my favorite role of him was general tran
yeah from from yeah he was awesome star
trek enterprise
he did all that edgar allan poe [ __ ] too
didn't he like you for a long time
he toured with that uh theater
production where he played edgar allan
poe and read from his stories and stuff
and um jeffrey
jeff combs i'm gonna call him jeffrey
all right i'm not on a first name basis
with but
let's go home mr comes saying mr co
respectful mr cones said well
one day once star trek really kind of
gets ironed out maybe i
i would like to do maybe like a
a movie that had
general shrine in it and and really a
lot of people don't like
star trek enterprise if you've never
seen that series it takes
a season or two for it to straighten out
but it eventually becomes a very good
series it has one of the best mirror
episodes of all times
in a mirror darkly one and two but you
won't really grasp
until you know all the characters of the
series because their mirror versions are
[ __ ] great
and it explains what happened to the
defiant from in the original star trek
with the kirk
where did the fight go remember kirk was
floating in the spacesuit
the dollians got it man it went into the
past
and then in the mirror universe that's
where it went
which is so bizarre man but he did a
great
military man general shran
he feels very legitimately
like a military general um
and he's an andorry and he's blue with
[ __ ] got a little weird
stuff in tennis i mean
he does a very very good character and
um
that's one of my favorite star trek
characters was general schrandt
he was kind of like andoria's version of
captain kirk
since you mentioned jeffrey combs i will
mention another sexy horror icon
yeah bruce [ __ ] campbell yeah
yeah if you're gonna throw men in the
mix and you gotta throw them in the mix
because
women and man yeah so um yeah him too
how can you not love and i've read a
bunch of his books
like make love the bruce campbell way
yeah if chins could kill
he is hilarious yeah that dude is
hilarious
and he seems like well both him and
jeffrey combs seemed like just awesome
dudes
because they don't you know this going
back to what we're saying about tom
cruise earlier who seems like an
arrogant douche
neither one of like neither bruce
campbell nor jeffrey combs seem at all
like that they just seem like super
humble
super you know grateful for like i said
i know
that it's not like it used to be because
i feel like way back in the
70s and 80s there was still kind of a
stigma
about horror so if you were in horror
movies it was kind of like oh you know
they're you just kind of using it as
stepping stone like to get into like
more serious movies
but the thing about it is that so i
think there was a thing where people
didn't really want to be type cast in it
because they just thought it was like
this shitty
cheap like ghetto genre but
honestly horror fans are pretty much the
most
uh loyal fans on the planet so
i i say embrace it i never really liked
some people that are you know they were
in horror movies especially if they were
in
real iconic ones and then later on it
comes out they're like i didn't really
like
horror movies i was just in them for the
paycheck or whatever i'm like that
always kind of like bums me out i find
that really disappointing
now t mentioned uh william marshall
he did the two black in the movies
as uh mama walde and he also played um
uh dr daystrom yeah in
uh star trek the original star trek
series
with kirk those are two great
iconic roles i think in american that
dude's also pretty sexy
yeah but is that enough is that enough
movies what else did he do i don't know
man that's
that's pretty good i mean you know yeah
i think i feel like enough that's true
but you know what i mean
if it's iconic enough i'm not bothered
he wasn't really
he wasn't really known just for horror
and sci-fi he was
he he had him he did a bunch of [ __ ]
yeah
but um she said top five see so i think
he might get knocked out
because you know i'm gonna say that
[ __ ]
eddie murphy did a great vampire vampire
[ __ ]
in brooklyn i [ __ ] liked that movie
it came out at a weird time
it flopped at the at the at the box
office
i didn't give a [ __ ] i saw in boston
when i was in the god scene and [ __ ]
i'm a big eddie murphy fan and i [ __ ]
liked that movie
i own it i think it's great i think it
aged really well
it aged very well i liked it better when
i saw it
now than when i saw it back then yeah
it's good
which is weird that happens a lot it's
got a good it's got a good
hearted vibe to it it's got a very which
a lot of his movies have i think that's
kind of why a lot of people
uh related to him i think that's why he
got to be such a big star because
his movies really do seem to have
they're not super mean-spirited
no and he hasn't changed much not really
eddie should make a sequel to that
i would like to see that maybe someday
yeah that would be cool
well you don't need the money that you
used to you didn't you don't need the
studios that you
you you could crowdsource a movie like
that well yeah like i said there's so
many more
options that would that people didn't
have back then
yeah um i wanted to mention earlier that
zach said that he had just listened to
an audiobook of uh no one gets out alive
which is a book that i reviewed a couple
weeks ago by adam neville which is an
excellent book actually
um and he said that they're making a
movie of it
i guess which actually that would be
cool i want to watch that that was a
[ __ ]
that was a good ass book i liked it a
lot you know i'm gonna read some of his
other [ __ ]
gadgey3 said my cat died oh no
please don't bum me out like that i'm so
sorry
that's so sad t says sig higgs was cute
with sexy too
only in a weird [ __ ] perverse way
yeah but i'm kind of into that though
like i said i like it sort of i like
weird dudes
when he was young in that movie um
what was the one it was a david
cameron's first [ __ ] movie
it was a alien ripoff he played called
con
uh [ __ ] started with c right i think so
he detamination or no
uh they go to an alien planet yeah and
sid sit a young sig hayes was in it
galaxy obtainer
galaxy of terror yeah he was in that
movie
that movie freaked me out as a kid that
was actually a pretty decent play i want
to get that [ __ ] on blu-ray yeah it's a
total alien rip-off totally
that's okay it was still good though um
victor garcia sent a five dollar super
chat thank you victor jenny i'm weird
[Laughter]
we're all weird i don't know like i just
you know you can't be like weird like
hey i'm gonna jack off next to you on
the bus weird that's
that's a different kind of weird i mean
like good weird you know what i mean um
what was i gonna say oh sid haig when he
was real young was
in uh a really weird ass movie called
spider baby
which was an old black and white movie
with [ __ ]
lon chaney jr in it yeah it's on
to be uh it's pretty weird check it out
it's like from the 60s
and he was like and he was pretty much a
kid and he plays like kind of a
special needs mute was he mute
i feel like he didn't talk yeah t if
you're gonna throw if you're gonna throw
a african-american guy in there i think
i'd have to agree with you that it would
be snipes
i was gonna say that yeah he had the
three blade movies he also [ __ ] did a
lot of good [ __ ]
in back in the 80s with uh he
he played one of my favorite villains of
all times from demolition man
[ __ ] he did he did a great and
demolition man is one of my favorite
movies i just watched it a couple days
back
uh what was his what was that
character's name
simon phoenix that's what his name was
the simon phoenix character was a
[ __ ] masterpiece and the writing of
that movie
is very good aged very well
um he also did some really good [ __ ] in
the expendables i think it was
expendable three
a lot of people don't like expendables
three but i never saw the theatrical
version i own it on blu-ray and saw the
the extended version the part that has
the cussing in it
okay because you see oh [ __ ]
jack hole wouldn't let him cuss in his
movie
chuck norris chuck norris doesn't allow
any cursing in his movies
which [ __ ] expendables three oh man
what century is it chuck
motherfucker's not in a century he's in
some kind of a [ __ ] time war
he's in a parallel universe he's just
stupid all right he didn't age well he
didn't mentally age
well honestly i remember him pulling
this kind of crap like even back in the
[ __ ] 90s
yeah cause like i said but for whatever
reason my ex-husband was super super
into like chuck norris movies
like he thought he was like a ridiculous
person yeah but
he really kind of liked all those like
cheesy like 80s action movies that he
was in and he was kind of like a big fan
so i've seen like every single chuck
norris movies like multiple times
even like the super shitty ones like the
ones where somebody goes to hell and the
ones with the
the one with the talking dog or whatever
the [ __ ] that was
i don't really remember it was did the
dog talk i don't remember
but um but i remember hearing like all
these [ __ ] stories about him that
he would like um i remember this one
time where there was a guy that made his
living being a chuck norris impersonator
like you know you'd hire him out for
your [ __ ] you know your
business opening or whatever and it's
like they don't say hey it's chuck
norris they say hey it's a dude that
looks like chuck norris come have your
picture taken i'll be hilarious
and um chuck norris didn't like it too
much and he sued that guy
yeah because he doesn't have he didn't
really seem to have a sense of humor
and i kind of feel like remember when
they when those books were coming out
like the chuck norris facts and stuff
and those are [ __ ] hilarious right
but i kind of feel like he was kind of
not all that down with that idea either
no he was he was trying to sue that guy
too yeah it took a while to soften up to
that
yeah and it's because the army liked it
army guys were doing chuck norris facts
and see he finally relented
i was like okay i guess they are okay
yeah yeah he's kind of a stick in the
mud but um
i don't was it two or three the one that
had
snipes in it and it in in expendables i
mean it might have been both
remember but he was good in the
expendables
expendables three directors cut on the
on the blu-ray
if you guys haven't seen that one see it
it's good it's very good
it's my favorite one i haven't seen the
theatrical cut it gives you the option
on the blu-ray evidently everybody hated
the theatrical cut
but the the extended cut from the
blu-ray is [ __ ] great
i [ __ ] loved it i thought it was
better than one and two
yeah just my saying and antonio banderas
knocks it out of the park
in [ __ ] part three at least in the
extended cut
yeah he's [ __ ] great character
somebody mentioned uh caroline monroe
obviously
yeah i'm talking about her a lot is that
horror well guess it's hammer horror
caroline yeah yeah and she was in like
some sci-fi and fantasy that came yeah
tony todd again that's another good one
he played candy man
drew barrymore okay carolyn would ruin
anything candy clark and the blob okay
i like that she was she was actually in
a lot of good [ __ ] i feel wasn't she in
the
[ __ ] man she was in cat's eye wasn't she
i want to say she was in cat's eye
the stephen king like anthology movie
what i want to talk about a little bit
about snipes though though
think about snipes all right for you
some of you guys who are old enough and
i imagine t
she's probably old enough to remember
snipes was one of the first dudes from
that era
in hollywood when we were coming up
is that snipes was black
like dark black he was dark black
he was like the ginger of black people
and gingers
are the white people of white people
okay
that was pretty deep thomas like that's
it and then like
and this was in an era where if you saw
some if you when you saw black people in
a movie they were kind of light-skinned
as if like trying to
bend the knee towards white people or
something they're white
i don't i can't explain it i don't know
the thinking of hollywood at the time
i think they thought that dark same
black people would not be popular on the
screen they were wrong
even even though [ __ ]
even though [ __ ] i don't know why
they were like that
because in rocky and then [ __ ]
predator
a man i'm [ __ ] drunk i can't remember
my [ __ ] boy's name
carl weathers yeah carl weatherson's
daughter he's like you know and he's
whacking my chair
so yeah and i was a huge fan of carl
weathers
i i had an element he's pretty rough i
had an element of hero worship on carl
weathers
all right uh and that went back to
predator one
later on he came out with a movie called
action jackson
that was a great movie i saw it in a
theater
this theater was packed with white dudes
watching it and loved that movie
and that was in michigan and i have no
idea why there was never a sequel to
action jackson
it was like an arnold schwarzenegger
movie but it had carl in it
and carl is on mandalorian and he's
directed some of those
episodes of mandalorian and and you know
what i mean and they were [ __ ] great
episodes
that dude is a a a unused talent
i you know and that he aged real well he
aged a lot better than people well i
mean him and like keith david and like
like they just seem like
they still look the same pretty much i
mean they look older but not really that
different
and and like that was another thing
[ __ ] keith david
he was just in uh what creep show
episode the other day
yeah keith david impressed the [ __ ] out
of me
when i was a kid [ __ ] in in uh
what was that one [ __ ] what was it
called the thing the first thing
man i love his voice keith david and
crustle
all right and keith david kind of he had
a real
[ __ ] tough guy swagger to him you
know
and he intimidated me
but it turned out he was like a hero you
know yeah
so and i [ __ ] liked it and then there
was that scene where [ __ ]
crustle [ __ ] goes no no no no no no
no no
we need somebody a little bit more of
[ __ ] even temper childs
and he's like oh yeah i see how this is
the white
the white dudes are in charge yeah you
[ __ ] i [ __ ]
you could read it at the time you know
what i mean you're like wait a minute
hold on
because crusoe mccready the mccready
character in in [ __ ] the thing was a
[ __ ] great character
[ __ ] that whole movie was a [ __ ]
that was carpenter's masterpiece
i mean easily one of my favorite movies
ever easily and that movie broke
carpenter when e.t kicked that movie's
ass
his movies were never really quite the
same it's almost kind of like he started
saying i [ __ ] it
well he got kind of disillusioned yes i
could tell because that movie was
[ __ ] great
it took a long time for that movie to
get the appreciation that it deserved
i mean i'm glad everybody did and i mean
honestly nowadays
everybody realizes holy crap that's like
one of the best horror movies ever made
yeah
i don't think anybody would disagree
with you on that it was a total
immersion movie you bought it
even though that some of the effects
were kind of cheesy by the today's
standards
it's worth it i think the effects still
like just look pretty good i think
they look pretty good i'm just saying
that on blu-ray
you can tell that that's not that that's
rubber you can tell that this is that
they still look cool um
in those days it was mind-blowing okay
wow and uh
at the end man you got [ __ ] crush on
[ __ ] and keith david and [ __ ]
wrapping that up
that movie they're out there in the
[ __ ] cool boom boom
boom
boom boom and you know what i mean
you're like i have a feeling that
[ __ ] crusoe [ __ ]
cooked keith david because remember how
when he was playing chess against the
computer he was you cheating [ __ ] and
he poured the [ __ ]
yeah whiskey down inside the computer
and fried it
well he says well i guess it's just me
and you and you're you just sit here and
just
go to sleep and he hands [ __ ] keith
he hands [ __ ]
childs that [ __ ] whiskey bottle
because i guess so
and it made me think that that was the
same as pouring the
the whip
because he still had that flamethrower
remember he had the flamethrower on his
back yeah
so i didn't know if they were kind of
suggesting that
that [ __ ] crusoe cooked him thinking
that he was the thing
yeah maybe well like i said that's a i
mean that's a [ __ ] brilliant i gotta
go back and look did crystal still i
mean
did the child still have his earring in
though
see now we gotta go watch i'm gonna go
back and see that again the thing is one
of those movies just like the shining
where i could watch it like every single
day and never get tired of it
um camp guys talking about uh divine
eating real dog [ __ ]
in pink flamingos yeah yeah i remember
that yeah i mean i
i honestly love john waters movies and i
love pink flamingos but i can't watch
that scene i just turn away it makes me
gag
but um i mean you know devine he was a
trooper
also he was great in hairspray as uh as
uh tracy turnblad's mom they did the
remake
and uh what's his ass uh john travolta
played the divine role which i thought
was kind of interesting because i'm like
look at john travolta
playing divine you know what i mean
essentially
like being like in a you know being in
drag and everything
and i was kind of like you know what
good for him good for him i thought that
he would be too self-serious to do that
but i was kind of happy
i didn't love the remake but it was okay
it was like better than i thought it
would be
victor says chuck norris is lame as [ __ ]
i agree yeah he is pretty lame t says
yes snipes is deeply chocolatey
phoenix says snipes was black no way tom
this was serious
serious acid dude and uh i'm so
observant
yeah colorism was big at hollywood it's
big in hollywood yeah
and then they start and then david june
says carl weathers buys all his police
cars that
buys all his cars at police auction well
hey that's a good place to
get them they're cheap all right dj
maniac says and bill duke is still
the blackest man on earth yeah bill duke
is [ __ ] great too though man
he was [ __ ] great yeah he is also
awesome man
he was in a lot of my favorite movies
commando
predator one mandy yeah
oh that's right i forgot he was yeah he
was the one that gave nicholas cage the
[ __ ]
axe and all that yeah he's in the
trailer he's [ __ ] flying
landing on his head and the flies in his
trailer it's looking funny oh man
he was great character yeah he was only
he was only in that one scene though
wasn't he yeah it was just like a cameo
yeah that was so [ __ ] good though
yeah
dave says chuck norris is a jerk if i
could change one thing in the world
i'd change all chuck norris memes to
keanu reeves memes because they're funny
and at least they'd be celebrating a
genuinely cool guy
yeah see that's what i mean i feel like
keanu was like much cooler than
they're saying ambivale 2 was good
didn't we just want did we watch
amityville 2 the other day or was it one
of the other ones because
do you guys know i did yeah yeah yeah we
saw that one yeah it was pretty good it
was pretty good it was actually closer
to the real [ __ ]
i remember the first couple they used to
show them on cable a lot back in the 80s
and i remember them being like
pretty decent yeah i did not realize
this
until i was looking at i don't even know
why i was looking at like because we
were probably because we watched the
second one
there are i think 19
19 amityville movies 19
i'm pretty sure there are 19 of them um
somebody keeps making this [ __ ] but the
thing about it because the amityville
horror
i mean obviously that particular story
which was based on the
true story written by jay hansen which i
don't think that was true that's why i'm
using the bunny rabbit ears
but the the story itself the true crime
that's a true story
so you can make a movie about that
there's no copyright on it
yeah you know what i'm saying it's just
like the valiska axe murders or anything
like that
you can make a movie about that kind of
about that [ __ ] david june sends a two
dollar super chat does tom
have a jack nicholson impression i could
probably do it but i had to be a little
bit darker
and be in the mood really you're pretty
drunk though no i'm not that bad
tila goes bill duke was in car wash i
haven't seen that a long time got to see
car washing oh my god wasn't george
carlin in that
george carlin was in there right richard
pryor was in that enemy bill 2 i
remember it being
we saw it recently it was good and it
was closer to the original
yeah it was real close to the original
case i think that's why we watched it
recently because i think better just
added it not too long ago maybe if you
guys couldn't
i don't remember but i remember we
watched that one
and i was like well i was thinking that
there was other [ __ ] i think the one
that i
remember seeing a bunch of times like on
cable was maybe
maybe the third one because i feel like
on cable they used to show
amityville two and or three
um then they would show psycho two
which i think a lot of people thought
was like a crappy movie but it's not
it's actually excellent
and honestly i've seen some horror
channels
and i don't agree but i'm not going to
hate that
will tell you that psycho 2 is better
than the original
psycho i wouldn't go that far but psycho
2
is actually really really really really
good i mean
just way better than it has any [ __ ]
right being
um so you know if you haven't seen it i
i would
suggest searching it out also
and i've been meaning to rewatch this
one too anthony
uh perkins was in another movie
when did it come out 80 485
i want to say i could be totally wrong
and it was called edge of sanity
because you know since he was norman
bates everybody's like oh let's put him
in a movie where he's like a crazy
person because he's obviously really
good at doing that
so they put him in a movie called edge
of sanity i remember that being good but
i haven't seen him for many years it
might totally suck
but i did see that it was on to be so
i put it on my list because i kind of
want to re-watch it just to see what
it's
just to see what it's like um you know
what i mean
uh somebody's talking about camp guy
another creepy as hell
stephen king's short story is called
dedication about a hotel maid that eats
the semen off a rich writer's bed sheets
and then her son becomes a writer
that seems a little off the wall for
stephen king i need to read some of his
newer [ __ ]
like i said i think the newest thing of
stephen king's that i read that i can
remember
is under the dome i think
i remember i read [ __ ] man i don't even
remember when that came out
i remember under the dome because i
checked it out of the library
from a buick 8 i had checked that out
the library or maybe i bought the
hardback when it was like cheap i don't
remember
but after that i hadn't really read a
lot of his new [ __ ] and i was like
actually amazed when i looked back and
looked like how much
new [ __ ] that he has put out that i'm
just kind of like i can't keep up
like i said i got all these other people
[ __ ] i gotta read too
[ __ ] man package did i yes this may be
pretty much
uh oh oh oh
oh look esther it's like it it's a i'm
buying yeah she was asking me earlier if
i got this
you also got there it is from gadget
thank shout out for daisy my we pal
thanks for noticing the non-lighted post
at kiss
shout out for daisy okay thank you
shouting out give a [ __ ] hey daisy
hey daisy yeah look esther here it is
hell's wasteland the pennsylvania torso
murders yeah marika's like remember we
did that show a while back about the
cleveland tourism murders or otherwise
known as the mad butcher
uh kingsbury run and remember i
mentioned on that show i don't think i
went
super super into it but i mentioned on
that show that there had been like some
other weird like
kind of torso okay will you be good okay
is there clothes on no we'll put them on
put our clothes on
come here she's like what where are we
going put her clothes on before she goes
outside
um but yeah so there were some other
crimes where
because the cleveland torso murders i
mean that [ __ ] was [ __ ] up they just
looked
hey look we found a torso or hey look we
found a head and a can or some [ __ ] like
that
this was like back in the [ __ ] 20s
30s i can't remember
but um there were some related murders
that happened in pennsylvania also
and i think i just kind of touched on on
the show but esther was kind of like hey
we just got this book
and it's all about that [ __ ] like the
ones that happened in pennsylvania
and i was like she was like we got two
you want one and i was like [ __ ] yeah i
want that
so there it is she was just asking me if
i got it so there it is oh i'm very
excited about this
thank you very much esther i love that
[ __ ]
i love reading books about people
getting cut up that's not weird at all
[Laughter]
did she go out no she put the collar on
and then she goes up to the door and
looks outside and goes
nah quite too hot probably too hot
outside yeah
but it's also not dark yeah when it gets
dark she'll go
she she does this a couple times you
know tonight she'll like let's go inside
oh and now she's got
rock it here yeah and that's coming back
in what you doing oh my god
super chat five dollars from victor
garcia says jenny start a book club
i thought about it yeah i thought about
doing like read along somebody asked me
like somebody um
put in one of the uh comments on one of
the vidi
like book review videos that they want
to do a buddy read
um for house of leaves so i may actually
kind of do that i've read house of
leaves before
like several years ago but i'm gonna
reread it at some point
for the show but house of leaves is one
of those books
where you really gotta like [ __ ]
commit because it's one it's long and
two it's like super super
complex got another super chat tila sent
five dollars
another one thank you best character
arcs in horror
okay so that's okay i vote for clarice
and the silence of the lambs
also by the way that's great by the way
is payday for me huh
[Laughter]
thank you very much taylor for the five
dollars two is that actually you and
that little thumbnail or is that just
some random
ebony supermodel that you picked
that doesn't look like a real person
that doesn't look like a real person
yeah no one's that pretty no one's that
pretty
and then uh yeah she goes then t says a
book club would be fun
it would actually and i do kind of feel
like a lot of other uh
book review channels have that maybe i
should start doing that maybe i could do
it on patreon or something
or i don't know maybe so you guys could
like read the same books as me and
we could like talk about them i don't
know just see how that goes well david
says jason long and tusk can't get into
it without spoilers but the only
survives because he does what he has to
do
that's their uh story arc somebody sent
us tests we have to watch that again
yeah that's uh i like that movie that's
a messed up movie i like that
it's weird really weird and disturbing
and i liked it yeah it's again it's one
of those ones that's kevin smith so it's
one of those ones you don't love it or
you're going to hate it because i know a
lot of people really hated like yoga
hosers and
yeah that kind of [ __ ] but t told me to
rely on my imagination she's rely on
your imagination tom ha
ha maybe tila is an ebony superman
yeah did you ever think of that nobody's
gonna
i'm trying to think like really good oh
man good character arc
i kind of feel like there are hmm
there are a lot of good ones in horror
movies because it's usually although i
kind of feel like
usually it's sort of like weakling
person
maybe you know what i'm gonna say uh
maybe
nancy in nightmare on elm street because
i really like how she starts out just
kind of this regular person and then she
just kind of like turned into this like
badass
track because he says you never know
who's up in these chats
that's true and then uh victor garcia
says you all need to still watch border
it's weird like that okay see
border weird movies yeah i'm all about
the working babies i love that [ __ ]
all right just remind us man we'll see
weird stuff
sort of in a way depends on what it is
depends on how it's weird
yeah i just kind of like weird for the
sake
i like all kind of weird it has to have
impact yeah tusk was [ __ ] weird
human centipede was [ __ ] weird i
liked it it disturbed me though
um i never could get through centipede
two
i'd get about 20 minutes into it and get
bored yeah i didn't love it
um i didn't love it i didn't love the
first one either but i just i was like
what what it well it's kind of like a
mouth pooping
it's kind of like disgusting you know
what i mean like no
[Music]
i don't know it's kind of like i i don't
mind those kind of movies and like
sometimes they're entertaining but then
in some ways i kind of feel like
if you're going so far it's like look
how [ __ ] gross and disgusting this is
i kind of feel like there's a line there
where
it's just kind of like you know stunt
movie making like edgelordy
t says chief brodie and jaws that's a
great arc and job oh also
uh yeah a matter of fact i just
mentioned i think i mentioned that last
time i don't know if you were here
t i want to get a uh like a really good
edition of jaws we need a lot of
speculation
because i've seen the movie several
times i always liked it but
i'll put that right there with like
close encounters of the third kind
it's a movie that you grew up with that
you liked
so you want a real good version of that
on hard copy so you can [ __ ]
pop that [ __ ] in there and watch it
it's kind of comfort
kind of a comfort movie you know
i mean i don't know man jaws is so good
it's like it's like the perfect
blockbuster movie it's like perfect
and honestly it maybe it's because i'm
like [ __ ] terrified of sharks
um so maybe that's why it really like
kind of hit that sweet spot more but
it's just like everything about it is
like really well constructed
oh that's another that's another movie
that i think was better than the book
right there i read john's by peter
benchley it's a decent book
but there's a lot of like random ass
subplots that really don't need to be in
there
like the whole thing about like the wife
having the affair and [ __ ] like that
didn't need to be in there so i think
that the movie is actually better than
the book there i said it
rick's rick shaw says i have jaws on
blu-ray it looks stunning
david june says i can't really assist i
really can't look forward enough to see
how tom reacts to thanks killing
thanksgiving this fall yeah because we
just you
know it's like where we're gonna save it
for things we're saving for thanksgiving
we're gonna do it for thanksgiving uh
t says uh jaws is an incredibly made
movie very effective
if you can get folks scared of the beach
to get in the water then it's effective
yeah yeah it's so good yeah
what are you doing you can't go in there
that's not outside
she's like bud she didn't give a [ __ ]
about it just i don't care it's not
outside
okay but i just want to open
you wanna go inside okay
she's wearing her tail she looks that in
her little tail wax
you want to go in a closet yeah she's
like oh going into the clock
it's disappointing
the light changes because we have a
light bouncing off the closet horse when
we open it it's like that
um yeah so uh
yeah so like i said jaws one of the best
movies and like i said because i think
zach mentioned earlier or somebody asked
me earlier like wow
put some more ice in there see any more
eyes uh no i'm right
a movie that was better than the book
that's another one jaws
was better than the book peter benchley
also wrote the deep
and i remember reading that book and i
saw the movie too but the movie didn't
really make much of an impression
remember jacqueline bessette was in it
who the [ __ ] else was in that
i remember i didn't love it
it was just i don't even know wasn't it
like [ __ ] buried treasure or pirates
or
[ __ ] man i don't even remember now
because i was excited i thought it was
going to be about like [ __ ] scary sea
monsters again
what's the best character arc i'm going
to say
if it involves multiple movies i'd say
luke skywalker
that story arc
although it's not horror but what was
the horror that she asked for
yeah okay then okay they're not that
that's that
okay then the best story arc would be
reg from reggie from [ __ ] um
oh good choice yeah reggie from from
what's called phantasm series
the whole series yeah we still haven't
done
we did phantasm one and we did phantasm
two i think
and remember we said we were gonna do a
video of three four and five
because those are all like totally worth
watching but i don't think we ever did
it yes have you seen orca i've never
seen it
yes yeah i love art is it good
um no well yes and no honestly
you know when we were yeah when we were
talking about
70s uh when animals attack movies
yeah orca was probably my other than
jaws obviously but
that was probably one of my favorite
ones at the time period although i also
love empire of the ants and kingdom and
the spiders
um grizzly is okay i actually just
rewatched grizzly the other day
and it was all right but the g3 set five
pounds in a super chat
daisy died i'm drunk and not crying
don't worry bad bro oh no daisy became
one with a force
man don't love me i like that yeah just
how it happens
go um go listen that queen song
you know what's it do you want to live
forever or what's it called nothing
looks forever
and have freddie mercury singing [ __ ]
i don't know man i think it would just
make me feel worse he'll have his teeth
want to live forever yeah yeah
that'd probably make you sad [ __ ] yeah i
would probably get that yeah
gilded age phoenix says teeth is also a
cool movie i agree i really like that
movie it was about
i don't think you saw it it's about a
girl with a vagina dentata
yeah i heard about it i think
he goes around like chopping people's
dicks off with her with her badge
as she would
i think one of the most underrated
horror movies
in recent years was that horror movie
called underwater
it was a basically an alien rip-off i
liked that movie
it had that girl from buff the vampire
slayer i guess right no she wouldn't
bucket where was she from she was a
twilight twilight
is there so people didn't want to see it
i mean yeah but that's a good movie
although she was in that movie that was
about the runaways right i don't know
but i got that movie right next to you
play joan jeff
i got that movie i got that movie right
next to like alien
and um you know the whole alien series
it's it's like that
and blade runner it's almost kind of
like it's from that universe
yeah i liked it they actually did a good
job with like not uh
complicating it with a bunch of stuff
and i was i liked that they kind of
just like started with the action like
almost right out the gate and like
just kind of kept it going you know like
here's like this shitty thing that
happened and then it's oh
it's getting even shittier and it's
getting even worse and yeah so the
stakes kept going up and up
you're weird goddamn water and then
there's like good characters in it and
they're all young and [ __ ]
working on this underwater rig and where
it's like it's in outer space and then
you get to the very end of it there's
all kinds of weird [ __ ] having you get
to the end of it you realize that wait a
minute hold on cuz
you pretty much is that what we're
talking about here
we're talking about [ __ ] elder gods
eldritch gods and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] yeah you know and it's and it's
and it's right
right there with like alien
and blade runner and prometheus it's got
that motif too it's like it's like
something that um
ridley scott would have come up with
quite cool
i don't know if they'll make another one
i really i think one of the best things
about it was the characters
i mean you actually i actually liked
even the comic relief guy like the guy
with the with the stuffed bunny that was
like
trying to protect the stuff bunny the
whole time that dude was a [ __ ] riot
yeah and like when he got killed spoiler
alert pretty much everybody gets killed
in this movie
um when he got killed i was like super
bummed out
so that's the thing like i actually
cared about the characters when they
died i was like bummed out about it
then another one in recent years that i
think was better than all the new star
wars movies and [ __ ]
it was a good movie that didn't really
get any play i liked it
elite a battle angel i [ __ ] loved it
yeah it was all right i loved it i loved
it it was i just wanted more of it
yeah it was a good opening movie
yeah for that you know because it
established that character and then you
find out that character isn't what you
thought it was
yeah and there's more to it and so i was
wanting
more i was like okay all right that's
the character
what's gonna happen now you know and
that would make a great
disney series doesn't disney own that
oh you know they may so it might
actually go that route
that's what i would do with that i kind
of feel like most stuff that's real like
universe building like that yeah is
probably
i mean the better format for it probably
be serious
and you see uh you have the technology
and disney has the money
to do that as a series right alongside
mandalorian
and all the star wars stuff yeah is to
do
a really good manga you know
series you'd have the right people
writing it
but that'd be fun well that's true of
anything yeah
with the same what's the name rosario no
not rosario dawson what's that woman's
name that played uh
elita oh [ __ ] i can't what's her name
some of you guys might remember but uh i
thought she was great in that in in in
that
and i like the [ __ ]
cg the distorted cg faces like you were
looking at a live-action
manga you know i just that's that was
cool
we saw that like three times in the
theater didn't yeah so like three times
and then i have it on blu-ray
that's right and it was like i
understand what they did
with the script and how they manipulated
you into caring about the character
you know what i mean they did all the
tricks that yeah yeah i understood it
but that's
that's the kind of [ __ ] that you you
need nowadays
you know it was
yes people would say that well that's
you know by the book and you're not
it's not all that sophisticated that's
not you don't need that kind of
sophistication to start
the series actually simple well it's
it's
it's more like it's everybody knows that
you're doing that but it's just kind of
like how effectively can you do
it can you do it right if you [ __ ] it up
then it'll be too obvious
and then you'll just piss people off no
i saw right through it they're trying to
get you to [ __ ] have sympathy and
care about that character
but i did but you did it yeah yeah
like i had to they're trying to make you
think they're trying to let you know
that this is a good-hearted character
with a mysterious background
and then you find out later that she's
like an elite combat cyborg
or an elite she's not even a cyborg
she's a robot
isn't she i don't think there was
anything essentially i don't think there
was anything biological about her
and um but i i thought it was [ __ ]
cool man i
wanted to see more well maybe
someday you'll get your wish maybe
they're they're
saying that there are rumors that there
might be a series
i mean [ __ ] man they've made series out
of stuff that was a lot less successful
than that so yeah i don't really see why
they wouldn't i also recently said that
it was a lot more successful than that
that a lot of people in the industry
wanted to admit that it made back all of
its money and it made the profit
it just it took longer to do it than
they than they wanted
but that it did it did build a fan base
during that
but there for some reason that's not the
one that they wanted they wanted
brie larson and flicking uh what is it
captain marvel and they and
that that that's that that's they wanted
that to succeed
sorry i'm like bummed out about but
you're bummed out about gadget you're
talking about
oh david the cat man
that's a bummer yeah i'm bummed out
i don't like to think about it i don't
like to think about it because i don't
know what i would do if something
happened to pokey
but you know yeah i'm just trying not to
think about it
because you know she's like our kid in a
lot of ways
you're like ahead of me probably yeah
yeah yeah way ahead you're way ahead of
me
yeah but at least it hasn't like [ __ ]
it's given me a lot of trouble but it
hasn't like shut
out completely no need for me says he's
been an elite a fan since the [ __ ]
80s
watching the manga yeah
like i liked the movie like it just you
know i thought it was i thought it was
pretty good
the author died though okay
i guess and uh he said the movie was me
the
the that all of it the manga too i guess
he's saying it was done with like love
which that's kind of what you got to do
man well that's what we were saying
earlier about whether you're making a
movie you know
if it's what you want to make maniac
says need to watch blood vessel yeah
you'll like blood vessel blood vessel is
cool
i liked blood vessel a lot i watched
blood machine on sunday with
uh with stimulating both visually uh
both both audioly
and visually plus boobs yeah you know
i said it before blood machine was a
[ __ ] great little series
i'd like to have more of that it did
feel like a very [ __ ] heavy metal
magazine didn't it
it did yeah i liked it and it was kind
of like a new direction for sci-fi
they need to do more of that
just the way it looked and the way it
sounded it was like watching a music
video
and a cartoon and a space opera
and then it had some weird misogyny type
[ __ ] going on where the
men were using women as machines or
something it had
had that kind of stuff pretty pretty
neat yeah it was super cool
yeah you know like i said it it gave me
a little bit of a mandy vibe too yeah a
little bit like mandy like yeah because
of that kind of like
visual you know that visual
orgasm type of yeah it visually was
[ __ ] stunning
and everything was very unique about it
including including like
the weapon fire he'd fire off that gun
and the [ __ ]
the the the the ray would stay there for
a long period of time
burning in the air that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
awesome man
what if they're ever gonna like do any
more of those probably i mean
you know well i think that particular
story is done
yeah they need to do more in that same
universe you know what i mean
yeah i think that particular story is
mostly done
i mean like i said i'm kind of digging
the way that people just can kind of
make something that looks like that for
practically nothing yeah
it's a new era well yeah well like i
said that's [ __ ] rad because you
could be
ridiculous i mean you can kind of like
realize your vision yeah on on basically
a budget
yeah that visually that
visually blood machines
was way ahead of the old dilo dino de
laurentiis [ __ ] flash gordon
but tonally it kind of reminded me that
in a certain way
you know what i mean not really no it
reminded me of that
in how intrepid it was in terms of
[ __ ]
artistic expression you know what i mean
yeah
you could take that kind of technology
and come out with a flash gordon that
would be
[ __ ] bizarre like an acid trip
and be a mixture of what you saw in the
old cartoons
and the and the dino movie
and what you saw in blood machines mixed
in with some [ __ ] like
a heavy metal like a certain element of
like eroticism that the movies had
and and you would have a [ __ ] amazing
amazing uh series flash gordon series
and and the thing is is that if you put
sex and drugs in flash gordon
then that you're not you're not
bullshitting you're not [ __ ] around
with the story because that was
in the original stories yeah you go back
to those old [ __ ] 1930s serials